being 10 o' I call this meeting as the
public works and highways committee to
order as chair of the house Public Works
and Highway I find that du the state of
emergency declared by the
governor pmic and in
accordance and the
Govern number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on Senate bills referred to this
committee with potential for executive
sessions to be held throughout the day
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members M of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and that the
public has access to cont
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting
via the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the elect
tronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting uh
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
27136 or email
HCS
l.st state. n. Us in the event the
public is on able to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are meeting with us and
assisting Brad Freeman committee
researcher and Christopher Shay please
note that all votes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote let us start the meeting
by taking a roll call attendance when
each member states their present please
also State whether there's anyone in the
room with you during this meeting which
is required under the right to know Mr
cler thank you Mr
chairman representative Abbott here in
the committee
room representative
post I am at my home and my husband is
here you representative
boards representative
bunker present um alone in my home
office thank you representative cludia
uh here present in the committee room
representative
grassie I'm here at home and my wife is
in the house as well representative evil
home alone in New
London representative
Edgar presid home alone in
Hampton representative
fauler I am homman Swansea and my wife
is in the other room representative
fidy I'm here in
Hillsboro temporarily
alone representative Graham I'm here in
the committee room in conquer
representative
Jack representative
kazinski representative
kazinski representative kalansky
representative
kolansky representative
makoni um present here in the committee
room representative Mills is here and
taking
attendance representative
Newman yes present at home in Nashua my
husband is in the house representative
Newton yes I'm home in Ro and my wife is
in the house representative
Peterson representative
Peterson just was
there representative
querry presid at home in Manchester
alone representative
samaro I am here in a hotel room in
Florida
yeah that's me giving you the stink
eye representative Thompson president
the committee
room representative
Boyd representative Boyd here in meramac
my daughter is in her bedroom asleep
welcome thank you I'll give
representative Peterson one more shot
representative
Peterson I saw him here a minute ago he
was here yeah we'll catch we'll see we
catch
later all right thank you Mr Clerk and
there is quum present um I would ask uh
that we open the hearing on Senate Bill
28 naming the courtroom in the second
Circuit Courthouse in Plymouth and honor
of Judge Edwin W Kelly and I would call
on the prime sponsor sen the gu to
introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman honorable
members of the
committee uh I'm here today to introduce
my Senate Bill 28 uh for the record
Senator Bob GAA District 2 this bill
names a courtroom in the second Circuit
Courthouse in Plymouth one of the towns
in my district in honor of Judge Edwin W
Kelly I was contacted by senior Judge
Tom Raa who wanted to recognize more
than 30 years of service that judge
Kelly has given to our state and its
people judge Kelly recently retired and
but he served both the state of New
Hampshire and our judicial system with
distinction he has garnered wide praise
throughout the Plymouth area and legal
communities across the state for his
demeanor his fairness and his knowledge
of the
law some of his accomplishments include
helping to create the Family Division
within the court system and working on
bail reform uh most notably judge Kelly
helped create the Circuit Court in 2011
which then chief justice Robert Lynn
noted was quote a herculian task end
quote throughout his various roles in
the judicial system judge Kelly has left
an indelible Mark and earned the respect
of Staff judges and other stakeholders
at the court he helped define the role
of an administrative judge in responding
to Citizens and other stakeholders who
had less than positive experiences
within the judicial
system I believe judge Kelly exhibits
all the attributes that one would look
for in a great judge I hope the
committee will look favorably upon this
bill and vote the bill ought to pass
thank you representative Graham and
members of the
committee take any questions questions
of Senator
got seeing none I would ask that
representative bordon be brought forward
to justify
welcome repres
Gordon representative Gordon uh I see
that you're still m
thank you thank you uh chairman Graham
members of the
committee thank you for your patience U
I also uh speak in favor of uh Senate
Bill 28 and naming the courtroom after
judge
Kelly uh I served under him as a circuit
court judge for many years but even
before I was a judge he was the
administrative judge of the court and I
saw the court Evol evolve over many
years when I first started practicing
law the uh the circuit court and
particularly the district court was uh
uh at at best uh disheveled it was uh
basically made up of part-time judges
all over the state and if you were a
practicing attorney it depended on what
court you went to what judge you saw in
order the type of law you were going to
type of judgment law you were going to
receive and when judge Kelly was
appointed the administrative judge uh he
did a number of things he standardized
practices uh he made it so that we had
uh full-time judges judges who wanted to
be judges uh who weren't doing that just
to build their resume but because they
wanted to do it as a
career uh and that was a huge
Improvement uh uh Senator G has also
mentioned some of the other things that
he done um such as adopting the family
court where we actually had family court
judges who wanted to do family court
cases uh which was a change uh he also
uh prospered the court in the sense that
he saw that we had new courtrooms uh and
new cour houses built across the state
and we weren't having uh our courts held
in places like in Franklin where you did
it in the old opera house on the
theater the uh he um he's done a great
deal to prosper the court uh and
probably the one of the most important
things he did was uh among the last
things he did and that was to deal bring
it bring the court into uh the 21st
century electronically so that people
could electronically file and people did
not have to uh go through the
the formal process of appearing for
everything that needs to be done and in
short I I can't think of anyone who is
more worthy of having a courtroom named
after him frankly in my personal opinion
I think the court house in Plymouth
ought to be named after him uh but uh
naming a courtroom uh certainly would be
an honor and I certainly would encourage
you to do
so thank you questions uh representative
Gordon see n thank
you
um if we can bring um Thomas raer
up Thomas ra
when okay whenever you're ready good
morning uh Mr chairman and members of
the committee uh thank you for allowing
me to speak here today in support of
Senate Bill
28 uh naming the primary courtroom of
the Plymouth Circuit Courthouse
commemorate the remarkable career of The
Honorable Edwin w
Kelly I've had the distinct honor of
serving as a judge in the district and
now circuit court for over 32 years and
most of that time for over two decades I
sat in the very Courthouse that is
subject to this
bill this afforded me not only an
opportunity to work closely with judge
Kelly but also to observe him as he
carried out many of his other duties uh
as administrative judge
I urge you to support this bill for the
simple reason that judge Kelly has
earned this recognition based on his
contributions uh to the people of New
Hampshire as the first administrative
judge of what was the district and
municipal court and is now the Circuit
Court over the two and a half decades
that judge Kelly served in that role he
defined the position as he guided the
court into the modern
era my humble opinion as New Hampshire's
first administrative judge of the
Circuit Court Edwin W Kelly did more to
provide fair and efficient access to
justice for the citizens of New
Hampshire than any other individual who
has ever served in the judicial
system given my limited time here today
I'm not uh able to specifically
enumerate the long list of major
accomplishments
uh that judge Kelly was able to uh
achieve during his tenure but let me
summarize by saying that through his
steadfast commitment to the people of
New
Hampshire he made the court more
efficient saving the citizens of New
Hampshire literally hundreds of
thousands of dollars each year through
his tireless efforts and eloquent
advocacy he created consistent processes
and procedures that gave a void
to many who had no prior voice in the
system such as victims of domestic
violence and child
abuse through his effective leadership
he modernized the court system and
helped motivate others to create a
Judicial System here in New Hampshire
that is renowned Nationwide for its
fairness and uh Progressive
uh processes a court system that is now
respected
uh across this
country judge Kelly is a great man he's
an outstanding judge and he is an
inspiring
leader we the citizens of New Hampshire
owe him our highest respect and S and
sincere gratitude for his outstanding
service and significant contributions to
the New Hampshire Judicial
System candidly I agree with uh
representative Gordon uh I believe the
whole Courthouse should be uh named in
honor of Judge Kelly but naming the
primary courtroom uh where he served as
the first judge in that
courtroom uh is the least we can do and
I implore you to pass this bill and
create a lasting symbol of our
appreciation for judge Kelly's
remarkable career and the amazing
amazing impact he has had on the New
Hampshire judicial system thank you very
much thank you uh are there any
questions
for seeing none thank
you we can hear from The Honorable
Virginia
ER welcome once again to public works
thank you thank you uh honorable
chairman Graham and members of public
Public Works and highways I'm Virginia
Irwin and a former member of this August
committee uh it's nice to be with you
again even though we're uh sort of it
distances but it's nice to see your
faces um I'm I'm here because I want to
uh support Senate Bill 28 as amended and
I'm not sure if the amendment has been
introduced yet it has not if you would
rather hold
off I would respectfully wait until it
has been introduced Mr chairman okay
thank you thank you very much and
uh Maria
s bring her
up good morning um my name is um good
morning uh chairman and members of the
committee uh can you hear me okay yes
great um my name is Marsha sink and I am
the CEO of of New Hampshire a Statewide
Guardian at lium program and I'm here in
support of Senate Bill 28 and actually
honored and delighted to be able to uh
testify in support of this bill judge
Kelly um is a remarkable man as has has
been shared already in previous
testimony uh from representative Gordon
and judge Raa um he was instrumental
back in
1989 when Kasa was first introduced to
the state as an organization that would
support children and families who are
involved in child abuse and neglect um
hearings with a casa volunteer um to
serve in the role of Guardian at lium I
have to say if it had not been for judge
Kelly's support and continued guidance
as the organization developed and grew
I'm not sure we would be be where we are
today with over 600 volunteer advocates
in every courtroom family and circuit
courtrooms throughout the state of New
Hampshire judge Kelly in addition to all
his other attributes that have been um
shared and his ability in in his
administrative position has had a
commitment to New Hampshire's children
and families that has just been
outstanding he was accessible always um
to to me and to others he was
uh flexible and um always interested in
exploring new ways that we could improve
our system uh and how we were managing
these cases of abuse and neglect uh
throughout the
state uh I have to say his fairness uh
he was sitting part-time uh in the
Plymouth Court when Kasa first started
and his fairness and judicial
temperament was outstanding and he
carried that with him into his role in
the administration of of all of the
circuit and family courts throughout the
state so I just really wanted to be here
this morning um
to um support this bill the entire Casa
organization is supportive of passing
Senate Bill 28 and in fact I would be uh
agree with uh judge rppa and uh judge
Gordon in their support of naming the
courthouse um in his honor uh but at the
very least this courtroom the Plymouth
Court should be a lasting um Memorial to
his outstanding outstanding work on
behalf of so many of New Hampshire's
citizens so thank you for the
opportunity are there any questions of
Miss
s seeing none thank you very
much with that I see no
other um people wish to testify on
Senate bill um 28 I will close the
hearing on Senate Bill 28 and open the
public hearing on joh a non gerain
amendment to Senate Bill
28 which names a roundabout in the town
of New London in order of Jesse LaVine
and I call on the the sponsor of the
amendment representative
evil thank you very much Mr chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Karen eel and I represent
marac District dist 5 uh New London and
Newbury and I'm here to introduce this
morning um amendment number 2021 hyphen
112h and as the chairman mentioned this
um amendment to
sb28 would name the uh roundabout at the
intersection of Newport Road and um
County Road in New London um for Jesse
LaVine and just as a preliminary uh
matter for the committee um I believe
our Town Administrator has forwarded to
you a um a letter indicating the support
of New London's Board of Selectmen for
this um this naming bill which I know is
um a prerequisite for the committee to
uh move ahead
um in its
discretion um I'd like to say several
words about Jesse LaVine um and why I've
introduced this um this amendment Jesse
is a New Hampshire native she was born
and raised in hopkington New Hampshire
she's a graduate of hopkington um high
school she went to Dartmouth College and
she has a graduate degree in public
administration from
UNH she SP spent her whole life in New
Hampshire but for a brief time in Boston
and then she came back up here
throughout her career she's been
dedicated to Municipal and County
government I got to know Jesse during
her 11-year tenure at new as New
London's Town manager when I was also on
the planning board and anybody who has
been on a planning board or in local
government knows that there can be many
challenges
and um among those challenges was uh how
to resolve a traffic issue at the
intersection of County Road and Newport
Road um at the time that she suggested
putting a roundabout there it was a very
controversial um issue roundabouts
really weren't uh well thought of across
the board as opposed to traffic lights
or just sitting at a stop sign
but her um recommendation was Innovative
and bold for the time and she uh saw the
future and she worked very hard to bring
it to fruition in the town of New London
and I think um even though for those
people that live in more urban areas um
the backups might be uh not so much for
us it was a great uh a a great thing so
we appreciated her efforts
um after New London she was assistant
Town manager in Hanover she was the town
manager in uh Bedford and she ultimately
served as the Sullivan County manager
she had to retire early um after about a
year when she was diagnosed with ALS at
age 45 which was tragic needless to say
during her Stellar career she was
identified as a rising star and the UN
union leaders 40 under 40 she was the
past president of the municipal
management association she was active in
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
she was recognized as County manager of
the year in 2016 she was a Lo uh leader
in rotary and in 2017 she received the
Raymond S Burton public service
award Jesse turn 51
shortly she's battled ALS valiantly as
she has fought for the good not only of
the citizens of our town but for the
region and for the state at every
opportunity that she could I'd like to
just read a couple of words that she
wrote uh when she was nominated for 40
under 40 for the union
leader local government is bottom up
democratic Innovative proactive
responsive accessible flexible
accountable social careful caring
measurable and effective local
government exists to serve the needs and
improve the quality of life for those
who live within its
boundaries and even though change can be
slow at times the rewards are worth the
effort the hardest days are often from a
mentality that it's all always been
done Jesse was an innovator she was
enthusiastic energetic she
was a model citizen of the State of New
Hampshire and I would appreciate your
support of this legislation to name the
roundabout in New London for Jesse
LaVine thank
you any questions from the committee for
representative evil
seeing
that I would call upon representative
clud want me to all
right
right I
amri the city of Cl I also have honor
again this term to serve as chair of Sol
County delegation my fth consecutive ter
I rise in strong support of this
amendment to Senate Bill 28 to name a
roundout in London in honor of Jessie
and although the roundabout is not in
Sol County all down the road I think
it's an appropriate honor uh for Jesse
because I worked with her in some of my
previous terms as delegation
chair's very Innovative she helped the
acquire more
land where a lot of our County Land is
and as a result of those efforts we
turned
that that's
a was you know no other
count I found it to be very entic
Innovative and up to the challenges of
trying to manage in small rural C All
County and I want to say in conclusion
that when time done she had to leave
early because ofing help did an
excellent job transitioning for present
County Manager
D signed the letter and I was presting
my hard copy probably
seen
F probably made the smoothest transition
to County manager that I have ever seen
before since I've been a member of
County so I urge this committee to adopt
Bill
Bill any questions of representative
from the
committee see none thank
you and now once again The
Honorable uh Virginia irn again welcome
back to public works thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee um
I am a former member of this August
committee and it is nice to see you all
again uh and I'm here to support the
amendment proferred by representative
eel to name the roundabout in New London
after Jesse LaVine I can think of no one
better to honor than Jesse with this
dedication and this location Jesse was
an administrator for the Town of Newport
uh for the town of New London rather and
for many years and then she eventually
came to be the administrator in Sullivan
County as the county manager she worked
closely with the delegation to move the
county forward to improve services and
to streamline
operations to quote William Shakespeare
though she but but be little she is
fierce if you know me she bested Me by
an
inch Jessie is fierce and passionate she
always did what was best for the town
and and for the county even if it wasn't
popular and it might have ruffled a few
feathers she is fierce in her fight
against ALS and in its infancy it never
stopped her from doing her job she is
fierce in how she handles
adversity I know this dedication will
mean a lot to her and to her family to
know how much we admire respect and love
her for her dedication and Devotion to
our communities so I urge you to vote
Yes on this amendment and I thank you
for taking my testimony and once again
it's nice to see you all again are there
any questions of The Honorable former
member did it
off thank you um J
none that is the last person I have
signed up are there any um members
representative
cff yeah I'm uh I'm having trouble
hearing the testimony uh the question is
I do not have a copy of the amendment in
front of me I'm having trouble getting
the information from this committee I
don't know I I checked into it with
leadership yesterday and I found out it
may be going to an email that hasn't
been activated I get notices of other
things
but I do not have the amendment could
you could somebody from the committee
explain to me exactly what this
amendment does in that does it replace
uh the existing wording in Senate Bill
28 or does it just add and if it's not
lengthy could it could it po be possible
that the amendment be read so those of
us on the committee that are going to
have to vote for it know what we're
voting
for now a couple of things did did you
get your email situation fixed with
house leadership and
it uh no actually they sent me a uh link
to the create a a uh password which I
created a password and sent it and it
went into Oblivion so I'm pretty sure
what's GNA have to happen is they gonna
have to hold my hand through the process
I will read the amendment um it does not
replace the the first part which is
about naming the the the Rome in the
second Court the courthouse PL it has a
section of Jess leine roundabout theant
RSA
4-43 the roundabout located at New
Hampshire Route 11 also known as the
intersection of Newport Road and County
Road in the town of New London is hereby
named the Jesse willine roundabout order
of
County government leader and New London
resident Jesse W line among her many
career achievements in the pursuit of
good local government Miss LaVine
advocated for and oversaw the roundabout
construction while serving as New
London's Town Administrator an
appropriate marker may be placed on the
center island of the roundabout then
signage the cost of design construction
maintenance installation of any signage
replacement signage or other markers
authorized under section two of this act
shall not be a charged to the state
however the design construction
installation of any signings or other
Market authorized shall be approved by
the Department of
Transportation thank you Mr chairman not
a
problem representative evil yes thank
you Mr chairman I've had a communication
from uh Kim hallquist who is the Town
Administrator for new London that she's
here and um Wanted to testify I asked
her to raise her hand um on Zoom I don't
know if the uh Tech folks see her but
she is here and she would like to
testify there she is thank you welcome
to Public Works in Highway
good morning uh chairman Graham and
members of the committee and especially
uh representative evil who represents
New London so well I couldn't agree more
with all of the comments uh previous to
mine about Jesse LaVine um the town of
New London enthusiastically supports
this bill to name the New London
roundabout the Jesse LaVine roundabout
this will make official what has been
the common understanding of New London
New londoners since even before the
roundabout was open
Town's people have referred to it as the
Jesse LaVine roundabout because of her
dogged support of the project and her
belief not held by all that the
roundabout would increase the safety of
citizens traveling on Newport and County
Roads Town's people saw Jesse as a
leader of what was at first a very
controversial project many had never
heard about roundabouts and many feared
chaos in Mayhem would result if it was
ever built Jesse addressed all of these
concerns with patience in Good Humor
until there was enough support to get
funding for the project now more than 10
years after the roundabout opened even
the detractors admit that the roundabout
is a big success this is thanks to the
efforts of many but in particular Jesse
LaVine who just wouldn't give up on
getting something that was virtually
unheard of at the time built in New
London we can't think of a better way to
recognize Jesse's efforts than naming
the roundabout in her honor thank you
very
much thank you are there any questions
from members of the
committee see none thank you anyone
else so raise your electronic
hand see none I will close the meeting
on the amendment to Senate Bill 28 28
and open up the executive session on
Senate Bill 28 and the non jine
Amendment uh
1112 I recognize representative eil for
a
motion thank you very much Mr chair um
for all the reasons that we've heard
already um I would like to move and it
is my honor to move um Amendment
111h 2H to
sb28 um for Passage
was moved um acceptance of the amendment
uh representative M second there any
discussion on the
amendment so raise your hand let me know
seeing none the clerk call the
role thank you Mr
chair representative makoni hi clerk
votes yes representative
suo I vote Yes representative
fidi yes representative Newton
yes representative
post yes representative
boards representative kazinski
representative
kolansky representative
Thompson
yes representative Boyd Boyd votes
I representative cludia yes
representative Edgar hi representative
eel yes representative
Martin I'm sorry representative Jack
representative Abbott yes representative
Faulkner yes representative
Newman yes representative
grassie
yes representative
Peterson
query yes representative bunker yes
and the
chairman full disclosure I have known
Jesse since she was the uh Town manager
in Bedford and my wife did go to
graduate school with her but I do love
that you Mr chair the vote is 20 in
favor of the Au to pass Amendment thank
you our representa recognized
representative for another
motion um first of all I just really
want to thank the committee for its
support of the amendment it means a lot
to um the town and I know to Jesse in
particular who's watching with us today
thank you um I would now like to move uh
ought to pass on SB 28 as amended which
would name the um second Circuit
Courthouse courtroom for the honorable
Judge Edwin Kelly who has been um uh
model judge for all of us um and I'd
appreciate your support for it thank
you will move to pass with Amendment
representative mononi seconds the motion
there any
discussion raise your hand say none the
cour will call the role representative
mcon I
clerk votes yes representative
samaro I samaro votes yes representative
fidal yes representative Newton
yes representative
post yes representative
boards representative
kazinski representative kalansky
representative Thompson
yes representative Boyd Boyd votes
I representative cluder
yes representative Edgar I
representative
eel yes representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Faulkner yes representative Newman
yes representative
grassie
Peterson
yes representative
query
yes representative bunker
yes chairman Graham yes
Mr chair the vote is 20 in favor of
ought to pass as amended thank you while
we usually don't do this for naming
bills is there any objection to
consent no Mr
chairman all
right calendar will be I close the
executive session on Senate Bill 28 and
we have a about 3 minutes before uh we
hear Senate Bill
32 one I
have on justifying
is s Bo
hello we can hear you Senor
sorry now waiting for the time the house
runs a little different from the Senate
is
your no that's fine I my I'm in North
Carolina and the internet is spotty so
forgive me that's okay I'd rather be on
the a bags
myself for
the time being
10:45 I will open the hearing on Senate
Bill 32 two and act relative to the
Fallen State troop is memorial and call
upon the prime sponsor Senator
bird uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee for hearing Senate bill um
32 I just want to um for the record my
name is Regina burzell I'm state senator
for district 19 which which encompasses
the towns of dairy Hamstead and Windham
and I'm here as the sponsor of Senate
Bill 32 which is
um the uh relative to the Fallen state
troopers Memorial this is actually a
very simple Bill back in uh
2018 uh we passed Senate Bill 300 which
was an act naming a
um sorry
um this the memorial will honor all the
Troopers who have fallen in line of Duty
since the state police was create sorry
was created in
1937 um I want to express my thanks to
the men men and women um in this um
police force uh they are probably the
best trained in the country um and what
this bill will do is like I said it will
honor the troops but also what it does
is stream it's going to streamline the
process that allows the memorial
committee to disperse the private funds
without having to continuously go to the
governor and the executive
counsel um what what happens right now
is because um because many of the the
memorial uh the memorial is going to
have a number of contractors so rather
than having to have each piece that each
contractor is working on to go to the
executive Council um it will allow the
um the um
contract it's a very
process and where the executive councel
and um meet only once a month it will
streamline the process of trying to get
the memorial going so with that I'll end
my testimony and try and answer any
questions thank you Senator are there
any questions from members of the
committee uh representative Thompson um
Senator uh how does the governor and the
council fall on this if you
know um honestly I haven't talked to
them about it but um I I can I was just
on the phone with them a little bit ago
I can um follow through I haven't heard
any when it passed through the Senate I
did not hear any concerns from the
governor's office or the executive
counsel thank you I had uh follow up
follow sorry um I have two very close
friends friends grp of Phillips and
triple lyd who were killed
in
and I think this Memorial is very
appropriate
thank I I appreciate your comments
representative any other questions of
Senator burel onate Bill 32
see n thank you thank
you talk to you
[Music]
soon there is a hand
raise from a Brian strong
welcome Mr
strong can you hear me yes we got you
now sorry my uh internet is a little
delayed uh thank you uh and good morning
my name is Brian strong I'm a lieutenant
with the New Hampshire State Police and
I'm also a member of the New Hampshire
Troopers
Association uh I'm here to speak to you
on the memorial I am the project manager
assigned to the
memorial and um I am hoping that you
support this minor change to uh Senate
Bill 300 what this will allow us it'll
allow us to streamline the process to
disperse uh some of the funds needed
along the way currently we have a number
of
contractors we don't just have one
General contract we have a number of
them and they are all doing basically
the work for uh for a
donation and if they happen to come upon
something that they need a part or or or
a piece of material um it will delay the
process for us to stop and go to
governor and councils to get that small
uh piece of equipment or material that
they need to finish the job all the
funds are private raised through
donations and there is no uh State money
that is being used for this and we ask
that you support this and help us
streamline uh the process to get this uh
built and we're hoping to have it built
and completed by the end of the summer
and I'm happy to take any
questions are there any questions from
members of the committee for theut ten
strong seeing none thank you thank you
very much
anyone else who wishes to testify on
Senate Bill
32 we should second justify again second
time seeing none I will close the
hearing on Senate Bill 32 and open the
executive session on Senate Bill
32 what is the desire of the
committee representative mcon uh Mr
chairman I would move on to pass on
Senate bill I will second that Mo uh
representative M has moved to pass
seconded by representative
cluder discussion from members of the
committee raise your hand if you
do seeing none the clerk will call the
role thank you Mr chair
representative mcon hi clerk votes yes
representative
samaro I vote Yes representative
fidi yes representative
Newton
yes representative
post representative post
[Music]
representative
boards representative
kazinski representative kalansky
representative Thompson
yes representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative cludia yes representative
Edgar hi
representative eel yes representative
Jack representative Abbot
yes representative
Faulkner
Newman yes representative
grassie
yes representative
Peterson
yes representative query
representative
query representative
bunker
yes this is representative query sorry I
was muted yes thank you
sir chairman Graham
yes Mr chair the motion ought to pass
passes
190 thank you and I will close the
executive session on Senate 32 there any
objection from members of the committee
to consent
calendar see none we will go on the
consent
calendar we will have our next hearing
on Senate Bill
116 um
11:15 sorry about the delay I especially
apologize to the prime
sponsor take a break until
know e
e
e e
will start
[Music]
the time being
11:15 I call um the hearing on Senate
Bill
116 and act Rel to the project to
complete construction of exit of an exit
on i93 and dairy and Rond da to order
and I would call
upon the prime
sponsor representative eril if she's
here I am here can you hear me a oh
video and everything yeah I found
it welcome back uh Senator Burnville um
and
bill6 thank you um Mr chair and thank
you committee again for hearing Senate
Bill
116 um this was brought on um oh for the
record my name is Regina burzell I'm
state senator for district 19 which
encompasses the towns of dairy Hamstead
and Windham
and I'm the prime sponsor of Senate Bill
116 and this bill um is relative to the
project of um exit 4A uh few um Dairy
has been Derry and London Derry have
been putting money towards um the
completion of exit 4A for a while um and
the Department of
Transportation um a few years I think it
was last year extended the time out two
to three years before um they could uh
finish it and it was planned um planned
to be done in I think two years now it's
um Extended out two or three or uh three
years and the town the dot has brought
it back um within I think six months but
this is basically a project that London
Dairy and dairy have been looking
forward to uh getting completed quickly
and on time because they have they have
a lot of economic development that is
planning that they had been planning on
um they can't afford the time that um
the do has um Extended it out um and I
know that this is unusual the 10-year
plan will um will be dealing with it but
I also feel that we need to let uh do
know how much it means to London Dairy
and dairy to get this job done on time
as promised and um maybe not necessarily
on budget we're hoping that there is
money from the Feds that will come in to
help um speed this along and with that
I'll take any
questions thank you Senator
um are there any questions from members
of committee for
I have one Senator and it may
be deferred to uh Mr Cass when when he
testifies but I was just looking at the
the current 10year plan where it talks
about
construction um being
done um 21 22 23 finish
up4 is this the delay that you're
talking about no I believe that last
summer they came out with a delay out to
24 but uh again um Deputy Commissioner
Cass can better Define that but um we
wanted it done to the 10-year plan uh
plan and uh they extended it out because
of the cost um because of the delays I
think the cost had gone up $30
million and so they had to push that
out thank
any other questions
to
Senator see n thank you very much thank
you have a great day thank you um the
only other person that I have signed up
to
speak um is uh Mr L Cass of New
Hampshire
[Music]
do welcome back to the committee
yes good morning thank you um can
everybody hear me all right I just want
to connection is there
good um yeah thank you for um letting me
uh uh testify to the bill I just want to
um make sure I clarify things so that
everything is clear I can offer a little
bit more detail from what um Senator
birdell had um had presented in terms of
uh and I'll do it very quickly so some
of the history of the project um so I
think um from what I understand and from
the testimony and and discussion with
with the Senate that the legislative
intent is clear some of the language in
in in the bill if it is strictly
interpreted may
be um a a a little concerning but um so
the the bill is described as the design
build exit for a project um to complete
the design build project named Derry
London Derry so we had proceeded with
this project uh under a design build
procurement which um which was all
intended to accelerate the delivery of
the project last fall when we opened
bids for the from the design bid
Consultants the bids were uh and and uh
as Senator had pointed out more than $30
million over our estimate and because of
that and and after debriefs with the
design build teams and looking at the
risk and the things involved um we
decided not to award the contract and to
take a step back and to proceed with the
project under a more conventional design
bid build
procurement um uh approach because of
the risk involved and in particularly
what we heard was because of the um
right of way Acquisitions that the
design build team was um was um asked to
deal with and they placed a lot of risk
in that um in that area so taking a step
back and doing a a conventional design
bid build procurement process we had
committed uh and we had meetings uh last
November uh to brief uh a lot of the
local
um um politicians in the towns on on our
um accelerated schedule to do a design
bid build procurement so um it does
compared to the schedule that's in the
10-year plan the 10-year plan had
construction funds um to build this
project between fiscal year or calendar
year 2021 and
2024 with the design bid build
procurement we have we recognize
certainly the priority of the project
and the needs and we have worked to
accelerate that as as quickly as
practicable and the schedule we laid out
committed to getting out to Construction
in the spring of 20122 so we have a
design consultant um already in board
we're working through the design and and
and things to have a contract ready to
bid in uh
2022 um but with the RightWay uh
procurement um uh uh RightWay
Acquisitions that are needed we uh do
think that that delivery schedule is
going to extend between 2022 to
2026 so potentially two more two years
longer than the schedule that's in the
10-year plan however we have noted that
there will be a opportunity there will
be a partial opening of the exit to
public use when you get to to um
essentially Route 28 if you're familiar
with the um layout and you know we
anticipate that probably sometime in
2025 so we may lose a year from what the
um uh original 10e plan schedule was
planned for
um um but um certainly not as but but I
think we will be having it open to
public use prior to the full build full
full fully Full Construction completion
so that's some of the schedule and the
details and I believe like when we when
when when we talked about um talked
about it with with the Senate that the
legislative intent was you know holding
our feet to the fire making sure that we
understood that it was a priority to the
towns of Derry and London Derry and
delivering the project as as soon as
possible and as close to the original
10year plan schedule at as possible so I
think the legislative intent is there
the the the specific language in the in
the 10year plan from from the schedules
and stuff that we've laid out is a
little challenging in in in that regard
so um I guess I would just leave it at
that and uh uh can answer any any
questions but we I just would close by
saying and we have assured the the the
towns and Senator bdel that we recognize
it is a priority and we are fully
committed to Prosecuting uh the design
and construction as expediently as
possible thank you questions from the
committee thank you Mr chair
pass my question is
the overrun of $30
million and then taking it back to some
internally and reworking that do you do
you anticipate and being out one more
year for the release of that bid that
you'll still be in that range or or do
you is the department hoping that that
number that 30 million would be a lesser
number we are um I wouldn't even say
hoping I would I challenge to say
confident but we are we are pretty
certain that that through a a
conventional design bid build we can
design out some of the risk that was
reflected in that design bid build price
so they were giving us a a a
construction price bidding it on 30%
level plans and there was you know
uncertainty in that that I think was
reflected in the price so I am
relatively confident maybe that's the
best way to put it that we can design
out uh some of that cost increase
whether it will be um you know fully
what our estimate is or somewhere in in
between there I do not believe it will
be $30 million more than our present
estimate it may be a little bit more
there is going to be inflation there are
going to be details that we work out but
I think
um we you know and that was part of our
decision to design to go with the design
bid build that we could not justify at
that time that cost increase and I
believe that we will deliver it for
um uh for Less thank you assistant
commissioner okay thank you Mr chairman
uh Mr Cass I just want to be clear does
the department may I ask have a position
on this
B uh not not not particularly no other
than I just other than I just wanted to
point point out what what we see is is
kind of some some confli conflicts with
the with the specific
language um from from what I understand
the intent to
be follow if this bill passes as
written what's going to happen what what
is wrong I mean and will you need 30
million more dollars complete the
project
or do it in a different way
if the bill passes exactly as written I
I just want to point out that the time
frame of the 10-year plan at this at
this point can cannot be met um I think
like I said we will get it started as
soon as possible we will get it started
and it will be under construction um we
will have a contract out next
spring um but we are not going to be
able to complete it in the
um by the 2024 time frame that's in the
present 10-year plan
so okay thank you Mr CH thank
you Thompson um Deputy Commissioner what
was the uh what was the original
estimate from your department for
this round round numbers it might have
been 59 something but um from a from a
and I'm talking construction cost as as
well now so not including the right of
way and the engineering that needs to be
done but from a construction cost our
estimate was um right around $60 million
and that's what's reflected in the in
the in the 10-year
plan and who was the contractor that
came back I'm sorry
Pa um who was the contractor that came
back with the 30 million over
well there were three proposals um since
we didn't award the contract um it it it
we we can't really talk about the the
the details of the RFP procurement
because we didn't proceed with with the
with the contracts so but the um you
know apparent low bid of of that was
more than $30 million over our our
estimate thank you siril
thank you thank you very much Deputy
Commissioner for coming today um so I
understand uh that it's recognized that
it's unusual to introduce a bill like
this out of cycle with the 10-year plan
um I understand your testimony that
you're saying that if this is passed as
is you can't achieve it in the time
frame so
what if we amended it so it was a
realistic time frame what would I mean
is there any reason you can see why we
wouldn't handle this during the regular
10-year plan process um in the next
term no
no
followup go ahead um I was just
wondering is
there a downside or an upside I mean I
to doing it one way or the other that
you can
identify uh this that for me yeah um no
I mean I I recognize I I certainly
recognize um the community's
um not even desire but the but but but
the the community desire to send a
strong me
message um I can I I can tell you and I
can tell you know senator bir all and I
did during the Senate transportation
that that message has has been received
and we are committed to to um you know
delivering this project as as quickly as
we can and I believe that the schedule
that we have laid out um has been
recognized and generally accepted and
that you know the the the folks want to
see us make sure make sure that that
that we you know hold to that schedule
and do everything we can to to meet that
schedule I believe that's what the
legislative intent is here so if if if
if this bill you know is is
is um changed along along those lines
that I mean that that's that's that's
fine it's it's your prerogative to to
send that policy um direction to the
department um and and uh we will do our
best to to meet it so um
but I guess my point is uh with or
without this this this piece of
legislation the the the we we're fully
aware of of that message and fully
committed to um delivering this project
as exped as expeditiously as possible
okay thank
you thank you uh representative AB yes
thank you Deputy Commissioner what what
I'm
um what I'm hearing is that this U
bill would
be uh
impossible to
achieve based on the cost and the the
bidding process going forward and maybe
it would be a good idea as
representative I
has said to include this because what
you're saying from a time frame is that
uh it's not going to be even bitable
till next
spring so to and that's one of the major
tasks that we have for
uh the next session is to uh or the
session beginning January is to come up
with the 10-year plan so wouldn't it
make more sense to just include it with
that rather than to pass a piece of
legislation that's
unachievable I I I yes yes I would say
so the the one thing I think about this
legislation is is to send that strong
message about the the prioritization of
of of the project and and and to that
degree like I said I think the
legislative intent behind it from the
discussions and stuff um is is is is
good and we're honoring honoring that I
just had wanted to point out that that
that the you know a technical direct
interpretation of of the way the bill is
written is problematic at this point uh
in the
project representative Ed
thank you Mr chairman uh and thank you
Deputy Cass for taking this question I
have the way the poos bill is written
again it talks about design build um I
take it from what you were saying is it
you're you're switching over to the
design in it and then constructing it if
is the way the bill is written right now
with change the way you're intending to
do it and wouldn't that would that cost
more
um I think it I think it depends on how
it's interpreted
um the way it is referenced as the
design build project named uh Derry
London Derry it doesn't necessarily
specific uh
specifically um require the design build
per procurement but um it could be
interpreted that way based on the the
the description in other words is
is I mean colloquially it's I think that
is how it was referred to because it was
being developed as a design build
procurement so I think that's where the
reference of the design build project
named Derry London Derry but it
doesn't uh and I think that's what I was
trying to point out some of the maybe
inconsistencies in the bill language
that that um in a strict reading of the
of the exact language
could be
inconsistent thank
you thank you Mr chairman um my question
would be about what might happen to the
10-year plan if we get a a big increase
in federal funding um is it just
accelerate everything up or are we going
to be picking projects out to to move up
the schedule based upon their they're
being ready to go and is that going
affect this
project I don't think it will affect
this project um I know even at the
governor and Council um we've had some
discussions um it came up from Council
gatas relative to um you know potential
earmark funding and thing things like
that and and um while additional funding
would certainly be welcome it is it is
not as important
in uh delivering this project at this
point as completing the design in the
right of way um process so it's not a
funding constraint that is dictating the
schedule that is part of the critical
path here um so I guess that's the
answer to your question and with regard
to the 10year plan um there is well I
hope we know more when we start those
discussions you know this this summer
about where things are in Washington and
additional funding and stuff like that
because there's been a lot of discussion
but uh not a lot of details to
date thank you any further
question see none thank
you good thank
you and uh there's Mr David uh Karen the
time administrator
bring
up hi can you hear me yeah welcome
Public Works and highways yeah I'm sorry
my uh my feed just cut off and rejoined
uh thank you for the opportunity just to
add some additional comments uh that
Senator blazes Dell presented in bill
cast as well uh just for your
information this project has been a
transportation priority for towns of
Daring londondary for decades uh it was
in the uh Federal record of decision
there were two goals for this project
one is to uh promote economic
development for both communities and
also to relieve congestion on Route 102
which is uh East and West Broadway here
in D which is our main
throughfare uh and uh again not to
repeat what uh what bill was speaking
about but you know unlike any other
project in New Hampshire that has a
regional transportation challenge uh the
towns of dairy and Londoner have each
committed $5 million in local dollars to
this project uh we've gone from the
conceptual stage from over three decades
ago to nearing construction and uh our
our concerns are a couple uh uh one is
that we think it'd be critically
important to have the legislative intent
that this project move forward to
completion as soon as possible uh the
towns recognize and agree with Bill's
position that final construction will
not be completed until
2026 that's just the position we find
ourselves in after the uh designed Bill
process was completed with the
unfortunate cost
overun uh so our recommendation is that
the committee amend the complt comption
date to
2026 uh that would send a message to the
next year's 10-year Highway
Transportation process that this H
project remains a priority of the
legislature in the communities and uh my
last comment is is that bill correct me
if I'm wrong but I think actually the
construction project is now viewed as
being in three phases uh the first phase
will probably be most visible to uh the
traveling public with a connection with
i93 the second and third phases include
uh construction and segments into uh
local roads in Dairy which will be part
of the 4A Corridor and our concern is
that without legislative backing uh I'm
concerned if there are additional cost
overruns uh the third phase may be in
Jeopardy and if that occurs in a third L
third phase is either not constructed or
delayed that would simply uh transfer a
current congested traffic situation in
downtown to a separate part of dairy so
again in closing I thank you for your
time and I think it'd be incredibly
beneficial to have a legislature go on
record as having this project as a state
Transportation priority and to be
completed by 2026 thank you for your
time thank you are there any questions
mrar from members of the
committee C9 that is all
of people wishing to testify that I have
um nobody else
under um the attendees have raise their
hand to
testify um I with that I will close the
hearing on Senate
bill6
and just want to say a couple things
with this is with any other bill that we
have in front of us um we have four
choices we can pass the bill as is we
can find the bill inexpedient to
legislate we can amend the bill as
suggested by Mr
Karen or we can retain the bill and make
sure it gets put into the 10year plan a
year from now
correct
um if we were to go with the amended uh
option um we're not going to get that
done today obviously um just for the
committee's um information I have
scheduled um the 19th of May for any
executive sessions that we don't get
finished
today so that said before we opened up
for
motion um does any of the committee
have um something they would like to say
about how would they would like to
pursue uh representative
Newton yes uh it seems like there's a
lot of questions with this bill uh and
the biggest one concern of mine is how
it's going to be
paid and I think that uh referring it to
interim study or or retaining it would
be the wise choice to do because it
keeps the pressure on the
do and we would have plenty of time uh
to make a decision to add it to the
10-year plan or do some other
alternative action for the second half
of our session so I would certainly
support uh a motion in that aspect and I
think it would be uh prudent to move in
that
direction thank you representative
eil thank you Mr chair
um I think it would be highly unusual
for our committee to recommend ought to
pass on um on a bill such as this which
is out of cycle with the 10-year plan
our tradition um at least in my
experience has always been to retain um
a bill such as this I find a challenging
to pass a bill um especially in its
current uh the way it's current set up
that we're I I wouldn't want to pass a
bill that's impossible to achieve just
to indicate legislative intent um we
have the hearing um record from the
Senate we have the hearing record today
the gaset process will also give these
towns an ample opportunity to represent
their interests this is of such vital
importance it's hard for me me to
believe that it wouldn't uh ultimately
make it into the draft 10-year plan
that's presented to us and for all those
reasons I would have a hard time
supporting anything but a motion to
retain this Bill thank
you any further discussion before I see
what we want to
do if not what is the pleasure of the
committee represent I'll be I I move to
retain uh Senate Bill
116 second second approv by
representative fluier seconded by
representative mononi that the committee
retains Senate Bill
Andes recognized to speak on this motion
I I agree wholeheartedly with
representative eel on the reasons for
retaining bill I think this is a
worthwhile project but I'm concerned I
would not want to pass the bill as
written definitely and the more I have
some questions and I think if we retain
it we have according to the house cter
we have until November 18th you know we
thought to such important we could pass
it then and hopefully we're going to
have a clearer picture of how much
Federal money hopefully we're going to
get from the infrastructure which I I
think is going to pass sometime this
summer or certainly early fall and I
think it's going to it may not be what
the president exactly want it but I
think it's going to be for real roads
Bridges Etc that's my hope but I think
we need to wait on this but I think our
intent is this is an important project
so I expect in the end I'm going to vote
for tent that has this project and gets
it done as soon as possible I but I
think we need to retain it to make sure
there's pressure on the do like the
representative mentioned to do this
complet m thank you Mr chairman I agree
with my fellow members but I just like
to say I understand the angs here with
the DAR and lond how long projects take
but I want to I want to commend the
department here on pulling back and
looking at an alternative way to get
this project done in Theo
B It's My Hope between that keeping this
and
retain that it will work out best for
to any discussion I do have one thing
for members of the committee that by
late fall when we will have to report
this bill out we will have a fairly
clear picture of what will be in the
10-year plan the gas hearings will be
essentially completed and we
can if we're not happy with what's in
there that we can fix this bill and vote
on it in January um it's not going to
change change what happens this year um
with the agreed upon as the Town
Administrator said with the agreed
upon timeline that's been laid out now
to take it through
2026 and I do agree with
Representatives people including about
holding their Fe the fire as well as
represent for and I realiz this not B
well for our member from da but
we all are sometimes on that way so any
further discussion if not the motion is
to retain house
116 cour will call the role
representative makoni
I the clerk will vote
no representative
suo
I representative falie yes
representative Cliff I'm sorry
representative Newton yes representative
post
yes representative
boards representative
kazinski representative
kolansky representative Thompson
yes representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative cluder yes
representative Edgar hi representative
eel
yes representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Faulkner yes representative
Newman yes representative grassie yes
representative
Peterson
yes representative query yes
representative bunker yes and the chair
gram
folks
yes 19 to one the motion
passes thank you and there I have no
objection to it on
consent executive session on Senate
116 um
is in recess until
1:15 when we will
hear Senate Bill
[Music]
e
e e
I'd like to go to the
like to
go why am
I for members of the committee
um it is 1114 we'll begin in just a few
seconds with uh the final bill of the
[Music]
day but the house always waits till the
right
time and I also want to make sure
everybody comes back
it looks like everybody's here or many
are going to be back um the time being
115 by my watch um which is the only one
that matters
um I will call the hearing on um Senate
Bill
26 and act relative to roads within the
Woodsville fire district order and I
would recognize the prime sponsor
Senator
G thank you honorable chairman Graham
and uh
members uh of the
committee about two years ago I was
asked by the haal board of Selectmen
it's one of the towns in the 27 Town
District that I represent to chair a
meeting between the board and the
Woodsville fire Precinct
Commissioners this meeting was intended
to explore changing the state mandated
form formula that dictates the raising
and appropriation of haal tax dollars
and the transfer of those dollars to the
Woodsville fire precinct for maintenance
of the precinct's
roads but the discussion ended when the
commissioners of the precinct basically
pointed to the state law and refused to
discuss any meaningful change to the
formula it is that law that section one
of this legislation seeks to
change current state law dictates a
formula that requires haval taxpayers to
raise and appropriate funds for the
highway department of the Woodsville
fire
Precinct it requires havil to pay the
fire Precinct over $50,000 a mile
roughly five times the $9,500 per mile
that it costs havil to maintain its own
roads consider that this state law
requires one political subdivision to
fund the highway department of another
that's no different than your town being
told by state government and state law
that it has to fund the highway
department of one of your adjoining
towns it is an egregious violation of
every tenant of local
control opponents of this legislation
will cleverly ask you to kill it in the
interest of maintaining local control
knowing the respect we and the
legislature hold to this fundamental
Prem premise of New Hampshire governance
the law we asking you to amend today
mandates that the taxpayers of one
political subdivision hail raise in
appropriate local funds to pay for the
in expenses of another political
subdivision the Woodsville fire Precinct
making matters even worse the state law
requires approval of any changes to the
current Financial arrangement to gain
the approval of the legislature and the
governor honorable members of the
committee this is not local
control rather this law preempts local
control and eliminates any semblance of
good faith negotiations as demonstrated
by the ongoing refusal of the precinct
to make any substantial changes to the
grossly lopsided State man mated funding
formula without passage of this
legislation local control does not exist
because state law
governs this
situation woodville's hired lobbyist at
a cost to Woodsville taxpayers of almost
$10,000 so far asks for time to allow
the parties to resolve their differences
but those differences will never be
resolved so long as this law protects
the state-mandated gravy train for
Woodsville which disenfranchise IES the
citizens of hail from voting on the
funds they're required by state law to
raise and appropriate every year for the
different political
subdivision I ask you is this a law that
you would support if your town was the
donor Town funding another towns Highway
Department sadly this issue has fostered
deep division within the community
failure to amend the statute will
perpetuate that division for the
foreseeable future and the state's
continued interference in this local
budget issue will continue to prevent
its resolution at the local level for as
long as it remains in
place section two of the bill was
requested by the Department of Revenue
Administration in response to the
Woodsville fire precinct's refusal year
after year to perform the annual audit
required of every political subdivision
in the state despite dozens of emails
phone messages and conversations asking
the Commissioners to comply with the law
the department will speak to this
section in subsequent
testimony and finally as an adjunct to
this bill it's instructive to note that
the attorney general recently found the
current administrator of the Woodsville
fire Precinct guilty of violating
election law by using funds from one of
the precincts for Enterprises to mail to
every electric and water customer in its
purview a letter advocating against an
article in this year's hail toown
warrant that's electioneering plain and
simple the Attorney General is also
investigating additional election law
violations for this last March uh town
meeting as well as reviewing the
financial operations of the Woodsville
fire precinct for possible violations of
state
law the multi-year audit mandated in
section two of this bill has already
identified although not yet complete
several violations of both the municipal
budget Act and the municipal Finance
statutes in addition the audit disclosed
an 11-year period of potential fraud
against the New Hampshire retirement
system committed by paying the
superintendent of the Water and Light
Enterprise $90 an hour fulltime wages
but reporting significantly less to the
state so that the employee could
continue to collect State retirement
income Mr chairman and members of the
committee I respectfully ask for your
support for Senate Bill 26 to restore
local control of hail's budget to the
citizens of that community and to
reestablish transparency and
accountability and ensure the Integrity
going forward of the business operations
of Woodville fire Precinct thank you for
your consideration and I'm glad to take
any
questions thank Senator are there any
questions from members of the committee
seeing none thank you thank you Mr
chairman and I will have to go because
our Senate is now in caucus our
Republicans and so uh I will not be able
to pursue to follow this uh this hearing
any further thank you for sure you will
thank
you um next I have about 15 people who
have asked to
testify um I would ask everybody whether
you're in support or opposition to the
bill to be
concise and if somebody has already said
what you were planning on saying not
repeat that um it is difficult enough
for all of the
members um who are on Zoom which is all
of us with all of the uh people who are
justifying to keep track and it would
just make things go a little smoother so
that we can make a a logical
decision um second up I would like to
call
Stephen Robbins
from here thank you um and if you
everybody could identify themselves and
who they represent if they represent
anyone my name is Stephen Robbins and I
live in Woodsville I've lived in
Woodsville um since I was three years
old in
1969 um and I do not support this bill
um I believe that that we have some
issues within our town that um need to
be dealt with locally not dealt with the
your level and
um I think that that this bill
and um Senate of GAA have worked very
hard to divide our
community and the only way that we're
going to correct this is to bring the
parties
together that this
affects and let us decide how to fix our
own problems
um
the the Woodsville
taxpayer will be double taxed
by by implementing this this bill um and
and I don't think that's fair to to
those of us that that live in the
Woodsville District of the town of havil
um again this whole the initial system
was built and designed so that so
that we were not double taxed and by you
approving this bill and moving it
Forward um we again will be double
taxed thank you thank you Mr Robins any
questions from members of the
committee seeing none thank
you next is um the town manager of the
town of hail Bridget codling hopefully I
said the name right if not please
correct nope that is correct can you
hear me
yes hi my name is Bridget codling I am
the town manager for the town of hail I
came to work here in hail in April of
2019 so I um have uh been looking over
this situation for the last uh two years
and have uh been able to do a lot of
research um related to this and have sat
through numerous meetings um related to
this subject so I uh thank you for
listening to us today um I'm going to
read you my testimony and then I'm going
to email it to you thank you um I'm
writing uh to provide you as
representatives of the people of of New
Hampshire information pertaining to
senville 26 relative to the roads of the
W fire district Senate Bill 26 as
amended in the Senate grants the
Woodsville fire district the option of
operating its own Highway Department in
maintaining its eight miles of roads at
The District's own expense the
Woodsville fire district like other
precincts is a separate and distinct
municipality from the town the entire
purpose of forming a Precinct or Village
district is to allow a smaller group of
residents to manage their own needs by
removing some power from the existing
municipality in this case the town
Woodsville has a separate legislative
body and a separate governing body
through which it exercises his their
power however with that power comes
responsibility specifically precincts
are responsible for funding their own
activities Woodsville has the authority
to raise and appropriate its own funds
from its own residents Woodsville is
free to raise appropriate and expend as
much or as little money as its voters
and governing body feel is appropriate
the town has no control over that the
Woodsville fire district should not have
its cake and eat it too the Woodsville
because Woodsville wants the independent
power to operate its own Highway
Department without accountability to the
town voters yet it wants the town
taxpayers the majority of whom do not
live in Woodsville to fund it even
though the town's Highway Department is
equipped with a cap incapable of
maintaining the precinct's 8 miles of
Road
put it simply to put it Simply Having
the Town Fund woodville's Highway
Department operations places the burden
of funding the municipal operation of
one municipality Woodsville on the
taxpayers of another municipality the
town while simultaneously depriving the
town Authority and accountability over
the expenditure of those funds this is
wholly inappropriate and runs a foul of
basic principles of Municipal governance
and
expenditures this is even more
Troublesome given the fact that the
Woodsville fire District's Highway
Department only serves the area within
its own Precinct boundaries three square
miles and provides no benefit to the
large the town at large the town of
havil should not be required to fund
woodville's own internal operations
which solely benefit
Woodsville I reate due to its importance
that the town of havil is willing and
able to maintain the roads within the
Woodsville fire district through the
town's Highway Department who already
maintains 72 miles of Roads the town's
Highway Department already maintains
these roads throughout havil and is
prepared to take on the eight miles of
Roads within the Woodsville fire
district the town is ready willing and
able to take onroad maintenance for all
of its residents including those in
Woodsville however so long as Woodsville
desires to retain its own independent
power to operate a highway department
within its borders it should bear the
responsibility to fund the same the town
of hail asks that you please allow the
passage of Senate Bill
26 thank you are there any
questions of um this Cod Lan from
members of the
committee raised representative
ful yes thank you Mr chairman uh manager
cing right now the the
Woodsville District maintains those
eight miles of Roads themselves is that
correct they do they have their own
highway department and they maintain
their eight miles of Roads yes right and
so and and the money for that comes from
the taxes that are raised townwide and
the formula gives them roughly 25% based
upon assess value is that is that
correct um that's part of it yes sorry I
should be asking for a
follow um
so if if this occurs that
uh if we take away that resp
responsibility you would still be
raising funds townwide and then they
would be
distributed between the Woodsville
district and everybody else according to
however the town
meeting approved of you know the town
budget is that is that what's being
proposed here with Senate Bill 26 what
it does is it takes away the requirement
of the town to fund the Woodsville
Highway Department um making Woodsville
responsible for its own operations that
they choose to have um for within their
their Precinct and they have full
authority over that um and then it
leaves it up to the town um at the at
the uh Town level to decide whether
there are services that Woodsville is
providing that the town would pay
for question still don't getting to the
point here that the town if the town
raises $100,000 for Highway Maintenance
according to the current uh situation
they pay a proportional share to
Woodsville approximately
25% sometimes it's up it's up to almost
30% so it it it fluctuates so so that
that reflects the amount of money it's
actually raised from that District
because it's based
upon a proportion of the pro rate share
of the assessed value so essentially
we're just giving them back money that's
raised from that district for Highway
Maintenance so so when you think about
um the two different layers of
government so you have the town and then
you have the precinct um there are
similar activities where the town is
providing um for example uh police
services to Woodsville so the entire
town raises about a million dollars a
year to have a police department and to
to operate that Police Department
however about 70 between 70 and 80% of
our police force forces throughout the
year and our dollars are spent in the
Woodsville Precinct of course when you
think about uh Equity um certainly um
hail at large is paying the the largest
portion of that but the services are
being provided in Woodsville so you have
to kind of separate the town from the
precinct the precinct is a municipal
entity it gets to choose um in this case
to have a highway department um and and
no one else has control over that but
the individuals in Woodsville um however
the rest of the town is responsible for
for assisting with paying for
that and even though we already operate
a highway
department and so the the difference is
okay that um the town's Highway
Department budget is about 780,000
woodville's Department Highway
Department budget has gone up to almost
half a million
so
that's that's for eight miles of Road
roads where we have 72 miles of roads
that we cover for 780,000 so even though
it sounds like you're you're you're
going Apples to Apples with with giving
them back every penny that they raise
it's it's not that
Equitable and same and it's the same
with welfare as well so everyone in town
pays the welfare budget um but the same
the same um ratio goes to Woodsville
most of our welfare dollars are spent in
Woodsville but everybody pays for that
because it's a
town thank you Mr chairman and M codling
question I have is what percentage of
the town's base tax rate is raised from
the fire district area isn't that the
majority of the commercial
property in the town of hail yes so
there's about 20% of the tax base in in
the Woodsville Precinct because of the
commercial buildings the commercial
Enterprises
there and C as I understand it
Woodsville provides C with Ambulance
Service yeah we pay about
$150,000 a year for
that all right thank you very much
any further
questions seeing
none um thank very thank
you Mark is on the
phone wheeler
stepen will be next
we will get to that later
right
um see Jennifer
berer
hello welcome to Public Works and
highways thank you um my name is j bu I
am the assistant Town manager for the
town of hail um I just wanted to give
you a little background about myself um
I graduated cumad from Caston State
College with a Bachelor of Science and
business administration and a
concentration in accounting um following
graduation I worked for several
companies in various Financial
positions in 2018 I went to work for the
town of permont as their executive
assistant um and I did anything from
them from selectboard meeting minutes to
welfare Administration to
finances um part of my financial duties
for them Was preparing and submitting
all Town financials to the Department of
Revenue
Administration and while I worked at the
town of permont I also attended number
of trainings um to gain more knowledge
and understanding of Municipal
governments including courses with the
LGC Academy about Municipal
Finance uh I came to the town of Hil in
2016 as their finance officer and
administrative assistant um part of my
responsibility ities included include
preparation of the annual Town
budget questions regarding the
calculation of the Woodsville Highway
funding started to arise during the
preparation of the 2018 budget
process uh as finance officer I made the
decision to move employee health
insurance benefits out of the individual
Department line items um into one line
item as a result of this this reduced
the total Highway budget by about
10% um and this budget figure is what's
used is in part of the Woodsville
Highway funding
calculation because of this change the
precinct Commissioners felt the town was
no longer providing them with adequate
funding um the town manager that hired
me retired in November of 2018 and an
inm toown manager came in uh to prepare
the 2019 budget uh the Woodsville
Commissioners then went to him to
express their concerns about the funding
of the Woodsville highway department and
I was redirected to calc calate the
woodwell highway funding to include the
health insurance benefits although I
disagreed I did recalculate the funding
and included the revised figure in the
budget um the Woodsville Commissioners
still continue to question the highway
funding calculation and brought up their
concerns with the new town manager who
was hired in April of
2019 the new town manager requested I
provide her with the information
regarding the Woodsville Highway funding
which I did um I gave her the
spreadsheet that I used as well as the
memorandum of understanding that was
used that the spreadsheet was created
based
on we both her and I reviewed the
documentations and agreed that the
spreadsheet being used in calculating
the highway funding did not accurately
cor capture the memorandum of
understanding so I was then asked to
revise the spreadsheets to more
accurately reflect reflect the
memorandum of understanding um after the
spreadsheet was revised we would hold a
meeting with the selectman and the
Woodsville Commissioners to discuss the
res visions and work towards reaching an
agreement about the funding
formula my revisions Were Meant to
provide a starting point for the
Selectmen and Commissioners to work
together to come up with a funding
formula which more accurately reflected
the memorandum of understanding the
Commissioners were unwilling to work
with this s board towards a
solution in an attempt to reinforce the
memorandum of understanding as law sb75
was introduced in 2009 and was passed as
amended however the 2009 change to the
law is unclear as to what the formula
actually
is therefore the town has had to refer
back to the 2008 memorandum of
understanding for its
calculations over the years since the
introduction of the memorandum of
understanding the town has typically
provided the precinct of Woodsville
funding that equates to 30 to 50% of
what the town budgets for our highway
department for example in 2008 18 the
town's Highway budget was
$769,500 and the town provided the
Woodsville Precinct with
$429,000 in funding for their Highway
Department that funding equates to 55.77
per of what the town spent on their
roads to further put this into
perspective the town spent that 796
th000 to maintain 72 miles of Road
within our jurisdiction while the town
provided the precinct of Woodville with
$429,000 to care for the their eight
miles of
Road that's
$1,687 being spent per mile by the town
in comparison to $
53,6 per mile being spent by the
precinct in 2020 when the revisions were
made to the formula the precinct of
Woodsville received about
$5,988 from the town which equated to
16.68% of the town's Highway
budget that reduced their amount spent
per mile to
$1,497 which is more in lined with what
the town spends maintaining our
roads to me it seems financially
irresponsible for the town to be
providing these large sums of money to
maintain through their three square
miles of Roads located within the 52
square miles of the town in addition
Woodsville property owners are property
owners of the town of hail and therefore
just as respons responsible to pay for
the maintenance of the town roads as a
property owner who say lives in hail
Corner the town has its own Highway
Department that is completely capable of
maintaining the roads within the
boundaries of the precinct of Woodsville
however the precinct of Woodsville made
the choice many years ago to ask the
state for permission to create their own
highway department and they were granted
that
permission therefore it is the
responsibility of the property owners
within the precinct of Woodsville to
fund their Precinct highway department
and this is what sb26 is attempting to
do I ask you to please vote for sb26 as
amended and give the town back local
control of its Road
funding thank you um I do have one
request if what you have just said you
have written if you've given us a lot of
facts figures and and the rest um if you
could email that to the committee I
would be truly
appreciative absolutely thank you you're
welcome there any other questions
for Miss berer from members of the
comme saying none thank you um I notic
that one of the other sponsors of the
bill representative wer is in attendance
I'm not sure if he wishes to speak or
not if you do representative Wilder
raise your hand
or that's
not bring one
um if all it says is new user under your
name I wish you identify yourself and
where you're from
and what your position on Hill 26
nothing all
right and we next he from Matthew V Rick
and I know I screwed
that hello
M
hello can you hear me yeah we can hear
you now sorry sorry about that that was
a wake up huh
um I appreciate the opportunity to speak
my name is Matthew melrick I'm currently
the vice chair for the holl select board
um I just want to reiterate a couple of
things um that um Senator G had spoken
about um we um they talked about local
control and we had I was part of that
original negotiation uh back about two
years ago and I sat we had approximately
three maybe more meetings that were
kindly chaired by Senator GA and
representative Rick lad uh themselves
they actually came down in N uh to
attempt to U help these
negotiations uh and they were completely
fruitless we had we had no no um nothing
came of those negotiations at all um
what I'd like to say is that this is the
antithesis of local control um this
Arrangement as it stands now is the only
one like it in the entire State of New
Hampshire where the state basically ties
the town's hands and they dictate to us
how our locally raised Highway taxes are
to be spent
um just like I said Woodsville is a
separate and distinct municipality and
under the laws in New Hampshire they
have the opportunity to choose what
services they wish to provide for their
own people so when uh in in part of
those negotiations that we had one of
the Commissioners had stated well we
just want our Highway money back but
problem with that thinking is when they
want their Highway money back to use on
their roads only within their District
they're not paying for the other 72
miles of road that all the residents of
of the town of hail use um and like
manager codling has stated you know
almost 80% of our police resources are
spent within that municipality there of
Woodsville but yet we don't partition
out the police Bill like that you know
everybody takes an equal share when you
join a town you contribute a little bit
and I think you receive a lot in return
and that's the case here because going
forward when you get 28 30% of our road
budget that has to be returned to
Woodsville what happens is going forward
for an INF for eternity every time the
town of hail decides they need a plow
they need a truck they need a grader
they need to 10 you know you have to add
30% to that purchase price to hand over
over to a municipality it's it's it's
really not a fair or Equitable solution
it's uh it's heavily weighted it's a
lose-lose situation for the town and and
we don't begrudge the Woodsville
Precinct anything they they have their
well within their legal rights to have
their own um highway department and you
know maintain their roads as they see
fit but they have the they have the
obligation to pay for it themselves that
they they can only provide the services
that their tax payers are willing to to
pay for and that's that's how I see it
should work
um it's it's
just it's just about fairness and and
like I said that's what happens because
it's it's a bad precedent to set going
forward so you know on a Statewide level
what would happen if the larger
municipality said to the state well we
have our own Police Department we don't
want to contribute to the state police
it would slowly erode and this is this
is just a law that really
needs to be changed and uh I would
please uh please please uh ask you to uh
vote for s26 as it is amended thank you
for your time
um representative
boy Mr chairman thank you and uh Vice
chairman Briel Brook thank you very much
for your testimony question I understand
from doing my due diligence that last
year the town of havil at their annual
meeting decided to create their own fire
department and that they would be
inviting the North havil and havil
Corner fired precincts into that um new
department that was created is is that
still the plan of attack for the town of
April oh yes sir our um it I'll give you
once over the world on that um the uh it
it that plan initiated when um the ha
Corner people came to us with the idea
of maybe becoming part of the town and
forming a single department so we put it
a at a vote to the town's people at town
meeting it was approved we had to
obviously get the town to sign off on it
first and and the bill as P the um
Warren article as past stated that there
was three fire departments within the
town of hail that was hail Corner North
havil and Woodsville so the town agreed
to if the
precincts uh approved to give up their
fire
responsibilities they would join the
town fire department and then the town
would pay for the entire department and
north havil and havil Corner both joined
the fire department which is now the
havil town of hail fire department uh
unfortunately Woodsville um the
Commissioners the first year didn't put
it they didn't allow it to be voted on
and I believe this year um they turned
it down so so they chose not to become
part of the Town fire department
unfortunately followup Mr chairman
follow thank you Mr chairman um Vice
chairman belel BR just so that I
understand because I I I appreciate the
testimony that uh Town manager codling
provided I'm just trying to understand
the
relationship of the Woodsville Highway
Department as it relates to the
Woodsville fire district are they a are
they a department under the Woodsville
fire District or are they a department
under the guise of the town of
hail no they they fall under the
Woodsville fire district okay so it's
their own Highway Department under the
fire district that's correct sir okay
wonderful thank you very much for your
testimony thank you Mr chairman thank
you for your time sir represent evil
thank you Mr chairman um thank you sir
for being here um you folks are so
involved in this and it's you know and I
think we're all trying to get up to
speed to understand uh the
situation um I can't find the statute
that this is amending on online so I see
everything in its totality someone
testified they said this is the maybe it
was you uh that this is the only
situation in the entire State of New
Hampshire like this so if if you could
just take us back in time I'm trying to
understand why this is in state law in
the first first place uh was it because
there was so much division um somebody
just tried to settle it through
legislation or how did this come to
pass uh this the original uh law I it
predates me obviously um I believe the
um over the over time there's been
numerous amendments and they've come
back to the state to amend it um I I
don't know I couldn't uh intelligently
speak to when the first law was enacted
regarding this but I believe the recent
the most recent amendment to it I think
was
2009 if I'm if I'm H
correct well I I I just as a followup
just as a matter of History I was trying
to understand how how this came to pass
in the first place um
so my other question is one of the
people testified that if this law was
past people in Woodsville would be
double taxed and I wondered if you could
speak to
that um sure well I I can't speak to
what um I think it was Mr Robbins that
stated that I can't speak to what he
what he meant but um double taxed um
well no because when you pay into the
high highway uh tax the highway taxes in
the town you're contributing to all of
the town roads not just you know a
specific Precinct so we like I said we
all contribute um I guess I could say it
like this for example we I I pay taxes
to the state and and by extension the um
the county for and that pays for the
State Police it pays for the county
sheriff's department yet havil we have
our own Town Police Department I mean
would you consider that double taxation
I wouldn't because the town chooses to
have our own Police Department so for
that we have to raise the taxes through
the town and pay for that it doesn't it
doesn't relinquish us of our
responsibilities to contribute to the
state police or the county sheriff's
department we can't say oh we have our
own we don't want to contribute I I I I
don't see that as double taxation um it
just if you want to improve your
services to your specific community as
we do with the town for example with the
police department it's just a burden
that we have to shoulder if we want that
so I I really wouldn't see that ma'am is
double
taxation just one more followup Mr
chair um okay so there's been a couple
of statements regarding local control
what is and isn't local control is it
your testimony then that the laws that
currently exist does not allow for local
control and if this bill was passed it
would return local control to um the
people of havil and
Woodsville yes ma'am absolutely just as
I had stated before if it would allow it
would it would unshackle the town and we
wouldn't have to be paying for a
department of another municipality so if
Woodsville wants to have a fire a a
road a highway department for themselves
then pay for it and then they the
taxpayer in Woodsville decides how big
they need or how you know how much they
want to spend to take care of their
eight miles of Road and then that would
allow the town to take care of its roads
with the funds that it
raises thank
you thank you
question uh Mr chair yes I I just wanted
to uh make a point um Mr Darren clogston
is on your scheduled list of people to
testify um when you're ready to call him
he have he has connectivity issues he
would be you he's here right now he
could use my uh laptop to speak to you
and address you there'll be a couple
people down of course just wanted to let
you know thank you sir
um Richard go next up
already in here you have to unmute
yourself Mr
Guy Mr guy you need to be onute you my
apologies I'm uh a little bit new at
this I'll do
that thank you very much I wanted to
introduce myself um in my eighth year as
hail Cooperative School board chairman
um I've spent 35 or plus years in the
town of havil on various boards and
commissions including being the
Woodsville Board of Commissioners
chairman in 2008 and N when the current
legislation was passed this current
legislation was the work of uh unanimous
work of the hail select board and the
Woodsville commission um the select
board under Rick lad we all know and um
Town manager Glenn English and it solves
some real problems that bill in 200
uh9 uh did receive unanimous support but
the ones the before you today is not
receiving unanimous support locally in
fact I believe you'll find that two of
the five tal select board members are
registered as opposed to it on your list
today and all of the Woodsville Precinct
Commissioners are opposed to it as well
unfortunately the bill before you today
recreates the very problem that the
current law was was
solving it has Woodsville property I'm
sorry Woodsville taxpayers paying for
its own highway department plus a large
share of the cost of the haal depart
department and it is considered or it
was considered double taxation back in
2009 the current loss solve the problem
and it works like this the people served
by the Woodsville Highway Department pay
for the Woodsville Highway Department
the people in hail that are served by
the hail Highway Department pay for the
hail Highway Department that is how it
works all of the in all of the
discussion today about how hail people
are paying for Woodsville or subsidizing
it's just plain ontrue and it's it's I
think because the people that are
speaking to you don't fully understand
how it works I think Rick lad has a very
good handle on it and I'm sure he's
spoken to you about in the past one nice
lady just a moment ago asked about um
the Woodsville Highway um uh having its
own department and I'll just throw in
that um we've had two Highway
departments and it's been mutually
beneficial and serve the town and
Village well for a very very long time
perhaps up to about a hundred years um
the bill we're talking about today is
only about
funding why are we here and and I'm
sorry but let me be a little blunt about
this prior to 2019 hail was a very
peaceful and Cooperative town the
highway departments work together when
they needed a little extra help um we
didn't keep a ledger of the time we just
did it um since the hiring of our new
town manager Woodsville has been under
siege from town management you will find
that the town manager is articulate and
Charming as you've just heard but she
has worked hard to disrupt all the
relationships using bullying tactics
that incl include threats of defunding
to enlisting uh you folks in conquer to
be uh her heavy hand she has defunded
the Woodsville fire department um over a
control issue she has threatened hail
Corner
Fire and they have pardon me she have
threatened havil Corner Fire Department
over um defunding and they finally gave
in she's attempted to defund or reduce
the funding or replace Woodsville
ambulance of which I was a member um and
still am for over 40 years now and the
public did speak up very har harshly
about that and they backed away from it
she's refused to pay the town's
obligations to the Woodsville sewer
department and she has Enlisted the
Senate and now the house to fight
letting Woodsville keep its local share
of Highway funds the people of hail are
not sending money to Woodsville if they
took the time to understand how it works
they would know that that the funding of
our Highway departments is simple if you
make an effort to understand it when
this started the town manager and select
board didn't understand how it works and
they believed havil was subsidizing
Woodville and when the town manager in
charge and as we recently found out she
has blockaded any efforts recent efforts
to get together and discuss this as a
group sorry I'm stammering a little bit
I'm not a great speaker at every turn
over the last two years the town manager
has been building a wall between hail
and Woodsville as the hail school board
chair I fear where this is going there
is now a strong sentiment in Woodsville
to disengage from haville this bill as
written could be that final Brick in the
Wall sorry for the Pink Floyd reference
if Woodsville splits from the school
district we will have a real problem
keeping our table Cooperative school
system going this bill is no more than a
tool that the town manager has found to
further her agenda I ask that you reject
this and return these discussions to the
local level we're given a we're given a
recent petition for her U dismissal and
voters taking back control of the select
board I believe we have a chance of
resolving this locally if you will
return this issue to us today thank you
for your
time Senator
boy thank you Mr chairman and Mr guy
thank you for your testimony one quick
question if if it if the voters do
choose in the village of woods of uh
Woodsville decide to merge their fire
department with the town of havil in in
your opinion with your institutional
knowledge does it solve the
problem I I'm not exactly sure what
problem merging the fire departments is
trying to solve um we have been training
our fire department Woodsville has been
training with the other two departments
for years they've done group purchasing
for years um we only have a a fire chief
with a $10,000 salary I'm not really
sure exactly what problem they're trying
to solve by doing this so um honestly I
don't think I'm the right person to ask
that question and be able to give you a
clear answer okay I a I apologize if I
put you on the spot Mr guy it's okay
it's fine thank you Mr chairman
any further
questions if not
um Mr
English me see if I can find them
there he
is welcome to Public Works and highways
Mr
English English if you're there please
on mute
so and they were call I I have Mr
English here if you'd like to okay sh up
something else but
okay
welcome can you hear me Mr chairman yes
we
can I want to thank you for the
opportunity to testify um in opposition
to S
sp26 as currently worded my name is
Glenn English and I was the havil town
manager from 1995 to
2015 I also went back for a brief period
of time
uh when my successor resigned and worked
an additional eight months to help the
selectman um get to a process of hiring
a new town
manager um I was a town resident and
taxpayer during my tenure and continue
to happily reside in the town I pay
taxes to both the town and the
Woodsville fire district where I am
involved in a family business during my
tenure as hail Town manager I and the
board of Selectmen worked hard hard to
establish and maintain a positive
working relationship with the several
Village districts which provides some
defined Municipal services to their
constituents within the greater town I
think the definition of municipality has
been um misinterpreted by some of the
people
testifying uh to me a
municipality that is totally separate
from another municipality is not the
same thing as a fire district or a
village District Municipal unit within a
town there are shared resources and
shared benefits all the people in havil
use the woods use the roads in
Woodsville as well as tourists it's our
business center all of the many of the
people in Woodsville use the roads in
hav so it's not like there are two
distinct municipalities with a brick
wall between them that's a that's a
fallacy um
many of the other districts provide
services that benefit the whole town as
well um I won't go into that detail but
we have about four different village
districts Water and Light departments
are done locally in the district level
um and one of our districts Mount Lakes
has a aggressive Recreation Department
that benefits the whole town in
instances um we have um our Traditions
honor government services at the very
local level that is why we have so much
diversity of our local government and
the town Administration the current T
Administration doesn't understand that
uh this has worked well over the years
as long as the lines of communication
have remained open and Cooperative
unfortunately that is not now the case
in
havil as I see it this proposed
legislation will end Fair Taxation and
local control for the Woodsville tax
fairs it will also mandate overly
extensive audit requirements on the
district well beyond any audit
requirements of any other
municipality s sp26 will end the long
established practice of returning a
percentage of Highway funds raised by
property taxation in the Town based on
the town's assessed values to the haal
taxpayers who live in Woodsville the
Woodsville taxpayers are also haval tax
taxpayers you need to understand that
very important this would result in hail
taxpayers in Woodsville paying for two
Highway departments paying for two
Highway departments double
taxation the second issue local control
requires a brief look at history the
Woodsville Highway Department predates
the towns Highway Department it was
established in the late 1800s to build
and maintain Woods city
streets these streets are paved and in
some cases have Curbing and sidewalks
enclosed Drainage Systems they are
expensive to maintain in relation to the
town's roads which are rural mostly dirt
with open ditches for drainage the
taxpayers in Woodsville are happy and
have been happy with their local Highway
Department in fact the Woodsville Fire
District boundaries were enlarged by the
Selectmen in the early 1990s because the
town was doing such a poor job
maintaining Swiftwater road which
provides access to Cottage
Hospital since the town government began
to make incorrect allocation of the
highway funds to be returned to the
district under the present Town manager
a violation of the current statute by
the way the district Commissioners were
forced to sue the town to protect their
taxpayers a mediated settlement or Court
action could ultimately decide the issue
if resolution is
achieved um any required enabling
legislative action can be brought to the
legislature by both the town and the
district as has been done successfully
in the past I strongly urge you to vote
s sp26 inexpedient the legislate please
honor our traditions of local control
and fair taxation and I would end with
reminding you and having you understand
that the
taxpayers in Woodsville are also haval
taxpayers thank
you L comp there any
questions see none thank
you you could have uh Darwin Clon I
think he's sitting with
Clon Clon are you
there good good good
[Music]
afternoon my name is Darwin clogs and I
don't own a computer so um mat Matthew
is letting me use uh use use his sir
um as I said my name is Darwin Clon I'm
speaking for myself I am in favor of
sb26 my wife and I have been residents
of Pike for over 30 years the last two
years I have served as chair of the hail
select
board Pike is one of the five Villages
of hail Pike North hail the historic
town center of Hao Corner Woodsville in
the district of Mountain Lakes We Are
One community but unfortunately we are
not all treated fairly or equally by the
New Hampshire legislature when it comes
to our taxes taxation or how we spend it
for a little history in 1990 there was a
request for revision to the legislation
for the distribution of Highway funds to
the Woodsville fire district it is
important to note that five of the six
individuals making this request were
residents of Woodsville much the same
happened in 2009 with another new legisl
ly mandated formula for the
subsidization of Woodsville on both
occasions there was no Town vote only a
decision by elected inhabitants of
Woodsville four of the five members of
the select board in 2009 were residents
of Woodsville meaning most involved
personally profited or benefited more
than other citizens in hail as
legislators I am sure you understand the
ethics of such a
situation almost two years ago the
select board voted you name iously to
pursue the statutory changes necessary
to make our road maintenance fair and
Equitable discussions with the
Woodsville fire district were quickly
negated by Woodsville Commissioners
smiling and stating the formula is a law
and the law is the law we cannot change
it on the town level negotiations were
not and are not possible with such
comments as and I quote no review of the
process is needed nor will it be
tolerated the state statute stands in
the way since the first hearing held in
the Senate which passed the repeal 240
in 2019 hail select board members have
been threatened and made to feel
unsafe Town manager Bridget carding has
been called useless and psychotic and
bimbo previous Town manager Glenn
English who you just heard from said he
would in I quote crucify her if she
attempted to change the Woodsville
Highway funding formula
codling has been the recipient of
exploding pornographic messages and
warned by citizens concerned for her
safety that she should not travel
unarmed there has been much said and
written about the town of havil in
Westville fire district in local control
there are people who have and will
testify the state law mandating Hao
taxpayers give Woodsville more than
$53,000 a mile for its eight miles of
road is a local issue that needs to be
settled locally we can
not only you can repeal the law
requiring haval taxpayers to give their
tax money by a legislative mandate to
Woodsville the issue of roads and
distribution of money has been a
divisive issue for many years Woodsville
which has eight miles of road to
maintain is legislatively granted
$551,000 per mile the rest of hayo
services 72 mil a road with 90 $700 per
mile left from the taxes raised the
taxpayers can only afford so much and
currently the New Hampshire legislature
is the only place the hayro taxpayers
can get released they are mandated to
give Woodsville their tax
dollars until the issue became
overwhelming and a new town manager was
hired no one really knew what was
happening a quick look at the book
showed poor stewardship in a situation
where Woodville was overpaid theand
mated amount just the years 2016 17 18
and 19 represent an overpayment by the
taxpayers of hayo to the precinct of
Woodsville of almost
$800,000 our solution which is before
you today giv every road mile equal
status regardless of where it begins
where it goes or how many deer or bear
cross over them it will end the
legislative mandates upon the hay
taxpayer and allow everyone to be
treated as
equals every Precinct has the ability to
create whatever Services it wants so
long as the want is paid for by a
Precinct tax and is in accordance with
state law a water company electric
company ambulance service or fire
department if they want it they can have
it and pay for it I am of the opinion
that the existing law has allowed those
responsible for the serious Financial
Obligations that have been precipitated
investigations by the Dr and the
Attorney General to act with
impunity they believe they can
manipulate the legislature through a
couple of elected
representatives this has given the
taxpayers a belief that if you have
money you can even take more from the
little guy the working family by having
friends in
conquered it's time for equal treatment
of all people of the town of hail please
remove the Mandate the legislature
created which interferes in hail's right
to govern itself please allow hail
taxpayers the ability to control their
own
destiny please restore the faith people
need to have in its government and most
of all those elected to
govern it is interesting to note that
the attorney general has just found the
Woodsville fire district guilty on two
counts of
electioneering it is my understanding
there are six more counts pending
ironically this returns one of the
Woodsville residents Michael Graham who
benefited in signed Road legislation to
the Hao select board after a 20-year
Hiatus from using government mail paid
for by taxpayers to having the police
remove legal signs from private property
this legislation and its profits to
those in Woodsville pushes the limits of
criminal
activity the use of government mail has
been brushed off by the state election
officials because the lifetime CEO
excuse me excuse me if we could focus on
the bill and not allegations of other
wrongdoing or other problems within the
town of holl as a whole I would
appreciate it my apology sir I ask you
sincerely to repeal the law mandating
havil taxpayers subsidize the private
Enterprises of Woodsville Commissioners
and allow all of hail taxpayers to act
as one family
thank
you any any
questions members of the committee see
none thank you for your testimony thank
you for your time sir and we will hear
from The Honorable Robert
clay welcome back to the general court
thank you sir I I I miss it sort of not
the zoom though thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee uh for the
record I was a member of the legislature
both the house and the Senate I spent 14
years and um I I truly do understand
what you give up to be a volunteer
citizen legislator and I will say right
now I would never support any other type
of legisl legislature because I think
this is the way things get done as to to
cill 26 the reason why I'm even involved
as a few years ago I just just for the
record I like to restore historical
structures so I was approached because a
few historical structures were going to
um be either demolished or turned into
apartments and I agreed to buy them and
fix them right now I have
four um two of them are under
Renovations and and two others are not
yet but I I also somehow got involved
politically and part of it was because
the tax base um havil I think is the
fifth highest tax
uh community in the state of New
Hampshire so I started looking at my
appraisals and the appraisals of other
important people and said okay um
something's not right so as we started
looking up came the uh Road money I
remember they were buying a grater for
$100,000 and had to raise $1 130 so that
they could give Woodsville $30,000
directly so we started looking at
exactly what was happening but what we
have
is is a is a longstanding dispute and to
to representative eel this started in
the late 1800s and there's actually a
court case a Supreme Court case in the
state of New Hampshire from
1893 and it just happened to discuss if
if Woodsville took care of its own roads
who were responsible for any accidents
or who held the liability and the court
back then said havil holds the Li
liability regardless of who actually
does it because hail is the town that
actually owns Woodsville in a sense so
and it and it's just gone on over and
over again now the reason why there was
a dispute is because in the late 1800s
the railroad was making a decision
originally hail Corner was the center of
the universe up there and that's where
all the circuit courts met I think three
months a year um every house in havil
corner including the ones I own were
either a Tavern a bed and breakfast or
both during all those years because
there was no place else for people to
stay so what happened was the the
railroad suddenly became the boss and if
you look at all of the the history for
the State of New Hampshire you will find
um the railroad became too powerful
controlled the legislature to the point
where there was an actual um serious
fight to get the railroad out so you add
into end up having money um allocated
based
on
um powerful
influences but it brings us to 2009 in
2009 as uh uh Mr claron said um there
were four people who were Selectmen that
were uh members of Woodsville and one
who who belonged in in havil corner um
who happened to be a state repap now
when you hear the testimony earlier that
said that uh the Commissioners in
Woodsville approved this deal and the
the uh selectman approved the deal well
when you have what do we have eight
people and seven of them are going to
benefit financially it's pretty hard not
to have eight people who are going to
agree now you also hear that um people
have said the law is the law and that's
exactly what's happened and
2009 um the representative and the state
senator uh put this before and I found
out from the representative on April
26th that they had a hard time actually
getting the bill from 2009 through the
legislature didn't like it so they
pulled a trick where you take it and you
put it in house bill to I'm sure you
most of you uh understand that that
process and that's how it came about
because it it was
then looked at as hey wait a minute I'm
not sure this is
fair so anyways it became
law and then the more they looked at it
they looked and said as you heard from
Jennifer um in 2018 or 19 they found
that they were making
overpayments and a
previous um manager actually had
admitted that yes he knew he was
overpaying Woodsville but he felt that
they deserved it but he also lives
Woodsville um and and so you know we go
on and on and on it's been very
difficult to sit with them and yes I've
been with Senator guer and and and Rick
lad in the beginning and we looked at it
and said how do we fix it well I I don't
blame Woodsville they smile and say
there's nothing to fix we get almost
half a million dollars a year because
the legislature says we do so what is
there to talk about there's no reason to
talk to
you and that's why we have to here
representative Rick lad said in 2019
when the bill that this was in was a big
Omnibus Bill and it was vetoed by the
governor because there was too much in
it um he said it's it it's it's none of
conquer's business conquer needs to get
its nose out of hail's business and I
agree with what he said but I don't
think he agrees with
why I agree that conquet should take its
noes out of hail's business
why does conquer think it's okay for
them to say havil gets this much
money and out of that money they have to
give this much to one
Precinct now the
precinct doesn't need the money they
said well they do because they want all
the tax money but when you look at it
all of havil including them use all the
roads so havil says we use Woodsville
roads you use havil roads we all use
every everybody's roads together so why
and why aren't we paying together and
what woodville's return return is it
doesn't matter what you use we take care
of our roads and we'll take all of our
money well you know it's
$420,000 a
year that we can't afford I'm a taxpayer
so I'm speaking as a taxpayer now we
can't keep doing this
now there's a second part of this bill
that I'm surprised nobody talked about
and it's the Audits and the audits are
tied
closely to to the road money which is
why they Dr asked to put their piece
in the audits show the misuse of Road
money some of you have been on the
committee long enough to know that
federal and state money comes with
caveats there are certain things you can
and can't do with it but how many of you
know that in 2009
they have they had
um I'm trying to see where it was the
the the the statement was made this will
provide Woodsville Precinct with another
$100,000 which will help in maintaining
the sewer system water
sidewalks problem is is all of those are
privately owned Enterprise systems not
entitled to taxpayer money and not
entitled to Road money Road money is
supposed to be used for roads it's not
supposed to be used to repair the water
system especially when it's a for-profit
business so when they started asking for
audits out of
Woodsville the town manager of havil
said to Dr oh don't worry about it's a
bunch of good old boys they just don't
understand but we know everything is
okay but as he
left certain things came up and Dr said
we need the help of the legislature
because we need to do this audit now um
they've done the audit because the AG
has stepped in and Dr has stepped in and
and I have um looked at it they have
some serious uh issues one that bothers
me the most having been on the New
Hampshire retirement system uh on the
board when I was in the legislature
um 11 years of having an employee they
called
part-time and I guess he was
collecting but he um uh they were
calling him part-time and then paying
him something that was called compal
time basically they were paying the
gentleman $90 an hour in telling the
retirement system that he was just
getting a pittance these are the things
that we're finding in the audit the
electric company is another one it's
supposed to be a municipally owned
Enterprise yet it sells um electricity
across state line which makes it
Federal the Pu is under the impression
in the state of New Hampshire that
because it's a municipally owned and it
only Services itself it can't regulate
it and the the answer to the federal is
we don't sell anything across state
lines well they
do and and where's the money I was part
of a
team that was um hired by someone to go
in and look for the money I've sat with
dick guy I've asked for the
information um I was told he doesn't
have it I was taken to the
superintendent and the superintendent
turned white we thought he was going to
have a heart attack and said I don't
have the books only dick guy does so I'm
not making any accusations I'm only
telling you what's in the audits what
I've experienced myself part two of this
bill is just as important as part part
one part one says to the
legislature kind of get out of our
business 8 Miles a road is nothing for
havil to take over and I will tell you
that the the fight um in havil during
the last election was to make sure that
the grater and the dump truck that was
necessary to to to work the roads um
couldn't
be they couldn't keep the lease contract
so they did something that basically
defunded but uh to the managers the town
manager's um credit she found another
way to make sure that she kept the
equipment to keep the roads going so
what we have is we have a a big
fight you're not going to fix the fight
over the roads unless the legislature
says it's not our business it's your
business and then I guarantee you
there's a group of people who want to
sit down and work it
out but Woodsville is not going to get
$420,000 a year because the town of
havil in its different precincts if
you're making money off the water and
you're making money off of selling
electricity and you're making money off
of selling the sewer
use then then you shouldn't be taking
our money to maintain them you should be
using your money the money you make off
of selling that
product and that's what we're asking
we're asking you to take conquered out
of the road
money and I'm asking you to um make sure
that
Dr can finish its audit work and it's
not just
Woodsville that would have to follow
this audit process it's everyone it's
time that
taxpayers had the ability
to see exactly what it is people do with
the money that's raised in
appropriated I can tell you that one
investigator I know has been on this
since 2009 on the electric they still
can't find out where the money goes
they're they're getting close because Dr
is forcing the
audit and and um there's a lot of things
happening a lot of people trying to
cover but but the reality is the people
in in in havil as a town all five
precincts a good
hardworking people they're working
families and they're trying to keep
their head above
water being number five in taxes in the
state of New Hampshire these are simple
people there's not a lot of luxuries
there and it's not fair the only fair
thing is for the state of New
Hampshire's legislature to say
this is your problem we're repealing the
Mandate that you give them this money
and you passed the second set so that
the people in Woodsville as whether the
PE as as well as the people in haville
know what actually happened to all the
money they've been fun fun funneling
into that
division Mr chairman I'm going to send
in my original
testimony I wanted to make sure that um
I answered some of the questions I hope
hope I did I'd be more than happy to
answer more um I've been around a long
time as some of you know I've been a
selectman I've been a budget Committee
Member I was a member of the House for
eight years I was a member of the Senate
and that drove me out um but I I I I
fully
understand you're finished I'm
done go ahead and finish Sor no actually
I actually I'm I'm I'm I'm done Mr
chairman um I I want you to know I'm
passionate I I have a place up there
that I'm probably going to
retire I
um it's it's a beautiful it's a
beautiful Community but what's been
happening to it over the years just
isn't right and and it's because um
people in hav roll are old fashion um
New Hampshire rights and they believe
that everybody is trustworthy and
sometimes it's not the case
representative EO you got a question yes
thank you and thank you uh Mr CLE for
the history lesson it just really helps
put some things in context so if I um
may see seem like a small point
considering everything else you
testified to but if I understand what
you just said there really wasn't a lot
in this statute about funding until 20 9
and when that and and that was
introduced I understand as part as of
hb2 and that's because at that point
there was already vast disagreement
going
on let me let me just say there there
was there was a formula in there but it
was nowhere near this and what it said
was that havil had to give Woodsville up
to a certain amount of money which meant
that if Haver was spending $9,000
a mile on its own roads it had to give
$99,000 a mile for the other eight eight
miles but it also said that should some
kind of catastrophe happen in in in
Woodsville that hail would would would
continue to be part of the thing it
wasn't until
2009 that greed took over and that's
been the
problem see no further question oh
representative clud thank you very much
Mr chairman
representative former Senator former
representative PL I have a question you
talked about this audit I maybe I'm
missing something is this audit been
completed um it's a it's five years of
audits um the first two years are are
done we're in
2017 um I've looked at them the first
two were pretty bad the 2017 isn't good
but um the rest of the other two years
are are not done yet okay thank follow
follow okay when when are all the audits
going to be done give us a time
estimate representative cluer I I have
to be careful with some of the
information I would strongly suggest
that you get with Senator guer and speak
to the the gentleman at Dr that's in
charge of this okay all right as
legislators you can get more information
okay thank you very much thank thank you
representative fidal
yes thank you for taking my
question if this bill
passes does it solve the
problem it it solves the problem because
it allows people to sit
down and and as I said with all due
respect if I was part of Woodsville and
I was getting
$420,000 I wouldn't sit and negotiate it
away but if it's gone would sit there
and negotiate how best to care for the
roads thank
you now further
questions thank you thank you
sir
um Mr stepen
Wheeler yes can you hear me yes yes well
first comment would be that the audits
are done all the way through 2017 and 18
and 19 are almost done and there is no
money missing there's been no
misappropriation of money the money that
comes into the precinct for Water and
Light is completely different than what
it comes into the precinct for roads and
them because Water and Light and the
sewer system and the ambulance system
are all Enterprise systems so that money
has nothing to do with wood thrill roads
and I've heard the figure of 500,000
400,000 425,000 we only get what is a do
us for the money I A precent
commissioner we get
23.6% of the road money because
23.6% of the tax dollars are paid by the
people of Woodsville they would like it
so we didn't get any of the money but
that is a fallacy and there's a lot of
other things that were fallacies that
would have spoken about by the gentleman
in front of me first of all the
Woodville Road started in
1898 this was due to because of the
railroads as he mentioned and the City
of Woodsville which is not a city but
it's a town was built like a city
because we had to have a sewer system
and storm drains because water doesn't
run down the streets too well and when
they're Tire Woodsville had a road crew
30 years before the town had a road
crew Woodsville maintenance agreements
have been modified many times over all
these years and the valuation has grown
this is based on property evaluations
assessing a tax assessments the last
update was held in 2008 which took
effect in 2009 that last agreement has
worked fine until
2019 at that time the board of Select
under the advisement of the Town manager
changed the formula without the precinct
of Woodville having any
input when they have a memorandum of
understanding you have to have all
parties involved in the changing of of
an
agreement it appears the SP board and
the town manager do not understand the
full understanding that that formul and
it was agreed to in 2008 because a lack
of understanding the precinct of
Woodville is not received their portion
of the taxes collected to appy the road
M this year at all we're supposed to get
it every quarter we haven't got a scent
yet and he talked about the uh the
select board actually in 2008 there was
only four members on the select board
because one had resigned when this was
done and they did not replace that
person until August and this the the
agreement was signed in April and two
were from hail and two were from
Woodsville but there all elected by the
town people of the town of hail so it's
not a lopsided board as he said and I
know that for a fact because in August
my wife came back on to serve her 11th
year on the select board at that year
she had been a selectman all those years
so I know that for a
fact the Woodville Precinct
Commissioners have tried to arrange a
meeting with a ha ha select board uh
many times and they refuse to meet with
us they said they couldn't meet until
the lawsuit was over well all we have a
we have a copy from their lawyer and our
lawyer that said that we should meet
because before we can even go to court
there has to be a mediation agreement
between the two so I don't know where it
is but and when one of the select board
members asked the town manager about
this letter and this email she said I've
never heard of it well five minutes
before that selectman got to her office
the next morning and she put on to I
guess I misunderstood what they were
talking about I mean it's just been a
same thing all the time that
23.6% of the road money comes back to
Woodsville because 23% of the road money
is paid by the presinct to Woodsville I
don't know why we shouldn't get the
money back that we've that was due us
because our taxpayers have be double
taxation again and they're also getting
double tax stations on the fire
department which we give 23.6% of the
money to the town fire department and we
don't get a sent back when we have our
own fire
department um and it it's just keeps
going and the police call they said that
75% of the police calls well I contacted
the U dispatch because all our dispatch
goes through Grafton County Sheriff
department and in the in the last
ensuing year 31.6% of the police calls
were in Woodsville at not 75%
31.6 was was done in Woodsville and most
of those were to Walmart which we kind
of
expected so I I mean the people in
Woodsville we had our annual meeting uh
two weeks after the
town after the town meeting and the
voters in Woodville at the annual
meeting for the precin of Woodsville the
sentiment for Woodsville was to secede
from the town of hael over the years
Woodsville has often perceived as a
separate town as many visitors to
Woodsville believe that they're in
charge lawyers come up to the courthouse
and they think Woodsville is its own
town they come to Woodsville we have all
the restaurants we have all the stores
we have all the businesses in Woodsville
for that stuff and the complaining about
tax money well all the rooms of meals
tax which is almost $200,000 a year goes
to the town we don't receive a sent of
it back and we have all the businesses I
don't know what the hell the problem is
there I just get I just get sick of
hearing all this stuff all the time our
road crew has to be trained because they
do storm drains they have to be trained
to go under the road with their gas mask
and everything when they go under the
road to fix a storm drain or sewer grain
our road crew does fix the sewer grains
but the and the money that goes
Woodville Precinct um comes to Woodville
Precinct water lights its own entity I
don't know how he figured dick guy was
going to because he was a Precinct
commissioner was going to give him books
for the Water and Light department when
we've been a separate entity until last
year at town meeting our annual visit V
visit Village meeting when they said oh
we're going to join forces we had not
been joined forces until the since the
1920s when Woodville water light was
established so I don't know where we
would have got that information from
I've been a I've been a commissioner for
over six years now and I can tell you
there's not one cent missing and the
audit that just came out there not one
cent missing from Woodsville yes we were
common Layman we didn't have a manager
at the time we may not have done
everything right but there's no money
that went from Water and Light from the
precinct to Water and Light because the
two did not get along and the problem
was the guy taking the money that was
retired had nothing to do with the
Woodsboro road crew because we had no
control over the Woodsville Water and
Light department they were their own
separate entity I just I just get sick
of hearing well Woodsville is this
Woodsville is that there's no money
missing we just and Senate the GU was up
there when they did the uh review of
2015 16 and 17 I don't know how how come
he said the 17 wasn't done 18 is will be
done Monday or Tuesday of next week and
19 will be done by the middle of May and
there's no money missing not one cent
I think that's about all I got to say if
you want to ask
questions questions Mr
wheer seeing none thank you we're gonna
try this one more time under attendees
there is some it says new
user
um phone number there is no phone number
there's um so we have brought you in if
we could that was who you are and what
your position on the bill is we would
appreciate
it I hope you're you're talking to me
I'm Kevin Shelton okay that was the da I
was gonna call next okay wonderful thank
you um I appreciate uh you listening to
me today I am in opposition of s
sp26 um if you make I'll read what I
have prepared and I will send it to you
folks
um I'm Kevin Shelton I'm speaking in
opposition of s sp26 I'm a resident of
Woodsville for the last 35 years
additionally my wife and I own property
both in north havil and in uh Woodsville
and as well as run a a business here
we've raised our family and have been
involved in the community uh committies
from Economic Development to being a
school board member for 10 years I
invested in our community
as a whole 14 months ago I was hired as
the administrator here at Woodsville
fire
district as you know there's been an
agreement in place between the town of
havil and Woodsville on returning Monies
to Woodsville for highways since
1990 this has been amicably amended
twice since being
created with the purpose of sparing
Woodsville Precinct residents and
businesses the burden of paying for two
Highway departments
as Woodsville has operated its own since
the late
1880s there has been an there has been
and is a disagreement on the funding of
Road monies between the two parties this
is a local issue and should not be
resolved with all due respect in
conquered the Woodsville Precinct
Commissioners voted formally at their
last meeting that they were opposed to
this bill and I know as you've heard
today that there's two two of the five
select board members are in opposition
of it as well
through the precincts attorney uh
they've reached out to the town to have
a meeting on road funding um and this
really needs time to play out they they
they need to get
together the second part of of the bill
um as amended is not relevant Woodsville
fire district is fully complying with
having the necessary audits they're
being conducted by plik and
Sanderson uh three years are completed I
know that was an early question and 2018
and 19 are near completion we have also
as a district contracted with plasic for
2020 that work will begin as soon as 19
is done and I hope that 20 is completed
certainly by the beginning of
July I would argue that the language U
at the end of this should not be tied to
any bill as it's an add-on and should
apply to all towns and districts equally
throughout the state and should not
single out one
Community um I before I close I I in the
14 months that I've been here uh I today
was the second time that I've heard of
electrical sales to another state the
Water and Light Enterprise company uh
serves the precinct of
Woodsville um it extends electricity up
135 North to Monroe uh Monroe Road in
the town of bath and it serves the uh
South on Route 10 uh encompasses the
Grafton County Complex as well as a
short Loop there for
electricity uh there is and has been uh
in my 14 months here zero sales of power
electricity to anywhere but New
Hampshire um we buy Power it comes from
Green Mountain Powers transmission lines
which comes in from Vermont um it is fed
from the North and the South and
wherever else uh but there are no sales
occurring here uh through Water and
Light U to any other place and I'm not
certain where where that's coming from
additionally um and I would be happy to
share the audits with anyone that would
like me to send them to them um there
has not been um in the audits any
co-mingling of money uh from the highway
to these other Enterprise funds and um
and the audit will show that um so
um in closing I I thank you for
listening to me I would ask you not to
support SP 26 and not be bullied into
voting for it this is a local issue and
it needs to be resolved at the local
level thank you thank you are there any
questions from members of the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you I see that representative lad is
finished up with his committee work and
I would like to ask him to briefly
testify I believe in opposition to
the well thank you very much uh
representative Graham can you hear me we
hear you okay good even though I'm
across the hallway um I would like to
thank uh the uh the committee for uh
hearing my testimony today for the
record my name is Rick lad L I live in
hail New Hampshire not hail
Massachusetts hail New Hampshire um uh
I'm a recent uh uh person to hail New
Hampshire we moved down here in 2004
from Alaska where we lived 25 years
there however um my family eight
Generations back founded the town of
havil New Hampshire and so I have a lot
of ties to this community I have chaired
the select board in havil um during 2009
very active on the select board at that
time I've also chaired the havil corner
commission which deals with the water
system there very active in local uh
Affairs um representative eel asked some
questions earlier about the history of
uh the U Road system in Woodsville I did
have the same question and then I asked
Beno peler who works in the office of
legislative research here and he gave me
a report about a year ago and the first
first issue that appears is in
[Music]
1877 then it goes 1887 1893 1899 a year
after the Spanish American war
1913 and then we get up to the years
that we're more involved with and i'
like to speak to that just very quickly
and briefly in 1990 representative Paul
Lamont put forward a bill it was HB 1138
which dealt with the Woodsville Road
system and how monies that were paid by
Woodsville folks and hail folks for the
highway budget up to 20% would be used
to support the system in Woodsville so
it went back to
1990 then s sp75 came about in 2009 that
was put forth when I was as a selectman
up there and chairing the select board
at the time but I also want to mention
to you that the other individuals that
co-sponsored this bill and sponsored
bill was Senator uh Deb Reynolds out of
Plymouth whom I know well and
representative Paul Inger Briton who
comes from Pike one of the areas within
havil which is not part of Woodsville
there are districts within havil that
have their own boards for various tasks
be it water be it fire be it planting
havil corner where I live currently and
then you have North havil Pike and you
have Mountain Lakes is and Woodsville um
North havil havil Corner Mountain Lakes
are primarily residential oriented our
revenues and our income especially if
you look at meals and room in rooms
income tax that stuff it all comes out
of
Woodsville and so um there are also some
uh bills in the past which we should be
aware of before we get to 4 414 HB 414
or to the uh Omnibus Bill we had last
year we've had memorandum of
understanding signed by both the
Commissioners in Woodsville and the
select board dating back to
1995 and then there was a proposal to
the first amendment of
theou in uh 2008 prior to
2009 in 2009 when we worked with both
boards
to develop this distribution funding
formula which is currently in law both
boards unanimously agreed to the
distribution formula in fact that's been
the way that all legislation referencing
the distribution formula has occurred
it's been unanimously agreed upon by all
those that are participating I might add
that one of those select board members
that was living in Woodsville at that
time in 2009 is now living down the
street for me in havil corner when we
were on the board at that time and I was
on that board we never thought of
ourselves as I'm from Woodsville I'm
from Mountain Lakes or I'm from North
havil or havil Corner we represented all
of havil so when we made a decision we
made a decision in the best uh the
betterment of all the whole good of the
town we did that also when we changed
how fire departments were funded
we used to fund all our fire departments
three of them havil Corner North havil
and Woodsville by the precinct voters in
those areas but there's a lot of havil
not in those three areas and back before
2009 or so the people outside these
precincts were not paying for fire
coverage at all so we changed that so
the town now assesses everybody for fire
departments and the money was then
distributed to those individual Precinct
departments
and yes we do have a town fire
department now that was recently done by
way of Warrant article but the first
time the havil corner folks were asked
to support the new town uh fire
department they absolutely said no we
don't want anything to do with it we
need to see a long range plan as far
what are the costs going to be how our
fire insurance is going to be affected
all that well the same issue is now
occurring with the
roads we have Woodsville which is much
different than the rest of the community
Woodsville is the commercial center
Woodsville has sewer water sidewalks we
don't have that except in one location
in North havil uh along Route
10 so the the cost of maintaining these
roads when we're dealing with water
under the roads when we're dealing with
sewer sewer our course are going to have
to be more for those eight miles roads
in Woodsville than the rest where it's
dirt or gravel or pavement and but we
all see and share the same need to have
good Transportation throughout the
entire
Community we when we went back in 2009
and looked at this distribution formula
I also asked at that time the town
manager Mr Glenn English who is an
excellent Town manager and has the techn
technical skills to produce a fiscal
report I asked him to put together a
long a plan which shows where are our
money's really being used to for because
at that time many people said well our
Police Department's always hanging out
in Woodsville so all our dollars are
being spent in Woodsville when we did
that analysis for all our departments it
came out of wash for the entire town
Woodsville was not receiving any more
than any other location within the
community
we also know in looking at projections
for where we're going in the next five
or 10 years the tax base is definitely
going to be in
Woodsville and you you have places like
Walmart there now our meals and room
Stacks our restaurants our mo hotel
motel lodging is up there in
Woodsville and I see the revenues coming
into Woodsville being much higher than
that at the rest of the community but
what the rest of the community is
residential and as with any large
municip IP ality or Municipality of
around 5,000 uh PE people in it you're
going to have certain areas which are
residential and certain areas that more
urban and have Urban residential yes but
they are more oriented towards
Commercial Business which I don't think
there's too many days that go by that I
don't don't drive up into Woodsville to
do my
shopping so going on down here when HB
414 came up in
2020 um both boards met with repes
Senator GAA and myself we were
discussing what do we need to do with
this there was agreement on one issue
now some people said though well that
that nothing came out from that first
meeting yes it did we have Highway money
which goes to Woodsville that comes out
of the operating budget for the
community you know that you you've heard
the split but there's also a highway
block money Revenue which comes down
from the state from dot to
municipalities and because it goes to
municipalities not to precincts or
districts then the share which goes down
to Woodsville comes by way of the town
and it's dispersed out we have been
dispersing that money not out not in the
same manner that the state disperses the
money to the municipalities so there was
agreement that we should use the same
process the same formula as the state
sends money to the to the municipalities
from this municipality havil to the fire
district Woodsville there was agreement
now there was no agreement in regard to
some of the other issues but I know and
you know that the first time you sit
down at a meeting you have to really
work hard roll the sleeves up and it
takes a while to get there it took us a
long time to get there in regard to
having the whole town take ownership and
how we fund our fire departments but we
did that now that we're in the fire
department business and and going that
direction the only reason why
primarily havil corner has opted to join
the uh the town fire department which
consists only of North havil is that the
fun money that was supporting our fire
department came down from everybody
raising revenue in this town through the
to through the town well with the threat
that we may not receive that money
obviously the the 190 some odd people in
hail Corner said well we we we'll we'll
join that department they did by a very
vote so there this there are issues that
we need to look at it takes time for
change um but the plan to move forward
wood roads what is the plan immediately
following when the town takes over the
Woodsville roads what happens to the
labor force within Woodsville what about
their benefits what about their
retirement how are they going to be
taken care of is there any guarantee
they're going to still be there what
happens in terms of the a long range
plan in terms of the the maintenance of
all the other issues water department in
in in Woodsville what happens to the
Sewer that comes from North havil down
into uh uh Woodsville where it's treated
and and taken care of there uh I think
the folks in Woodsville as the people in
havil corner were looking for yes we
want to we want to work towards all
being one town working together and
which we try to do but we need to see
the plan
how's that going to impact our our local
expenses our assets our revenues and if
that can be all laid out then people are
willing to sit down and talk I don't
believe that's all been laid out to the
Woodsville fire
district this is a very divisive issue
and there is litigation going on right
now which is a shame that each of us in
Woodsville and the rest of the town are
having to use our local revenues to
fight each other this has to stop uh it
just cannot continue in regard to the
audit I have spoken with the manager
that's been recently hired who comes
back comes to us from industry here in
New Hampshire um and has a good
understanding how to manage how to
administrate uh units such as the
Woodsville uh departments which have
been now merged into one Under One Roof
which he manages and there the first
several years yes errors have been found
they found found errors in other areas a
haal when we had our audits done for our
annual audit they found errors in ponts
too which permont went through a
disastrous time several years back so
these things happen but it's not
fraudulent and nothing has been proven
to be fraudulent in the audit the audit
should be done sometime later this
summer and I think it's very premature
to be acting on a bill such as this
without having a good strong knowledge
of what that audit has netted us and we
don't have that yet so I I'm not
supportive of this bill I think the bill
has a lot of areas which um need really
a good stiff look at um there's areas in
which the distribution formula was
agreed by all in the community and by
that I mean all those that lived in
havil and it's um it's it's worked uh
now there might be some disagreement as
to what is the definition of a net
operating budget versus the highway
operating budget that could be easily
easily resolved by just putting
definition into the
statute also it could be made you know a
statute could be a amended somewhere
along the way I don't know if this is
the time to do it perhaps not but a a
statute could be amended stating that
any future changes are may be done by
the two boards the Commissioners and and
the select board working to together
without having to have the approval of
the general court there's a lot of
things that can be done here and that is
why we need to really take some time
here and I urge this committee to take
some time in looking at this this has
been highly contentious down in in the
community we've had this before when it
came to our schools folks in hail Corner
didn't like the idea of taking hail
Academy out of hail corner and taking
High School up to Woodsville so it's
nothing new we sort of got getting out
of that old cultural thinking and we're
becoming a town in terms of our schools
hail is an old Community much like
Conway used to be with their precincts
we're getting there we're moving there
but we have to move there with uh uh
with foresight and with a good look at
what we're going to be five to 10 years
down the road we want to move to
something that's going to not cost us
out of the business we want to move Pro
that we have something that's more
efficient and we need to work there
together so we all have ownership in it
right now by the state making a decision
on this
issue we're we're just mandating pil
this is how things will happen there's
no ownership that's going to come about
that and we really run the risk of
having one Precinct trying to become
their own
municipality article 24 in 2020 which
was on our town
report asked the voters whether they
wanted to take over ownership of the
highway system in
Woodsville contingent upon the
Woodsville
residents
agreeing when it went to the Woodsville
residents for the agreement the vote was
52 to Zer not to join havil at this
time there was no plan paralleling that
request or that article so in conclusion
I know I've talked quite a bit here I'm
willing to take questions but I urge you
to go cautiously on this Bill thank you
very much thank you are there any
questions from members of the committee
seeing n thank you representative Vlad
um I'm looking for um at one point there
was a representative from the
Dr um on the attendee list
if there is somebody from the
Dr um I would like to hear from you at
this
point um let's
bring
Mr
G yes
sir you are
with are you with the Dr yes I am uh my
name is Jam just talk a little bit about
the audit of what you know and I'm going
to preface this all by a request that
you send whatever parts of the completed
a audit you can to members of the
committee okay well we uh certainly
first thank you for uh entertaining me
and allowing me to speak on this
important legislation
uh there are there are you know two
parts of the legislation I'm not going
to comment as the Dr takes no position
on the first part of the
legislation uh the the second part of
the legislation is really what we care
about and it is really because
RSA uh 41 31a states that Financial
audits play a fundamentally vital role
in helping to preserve the Integrity of
the Public Finance functions by
maintaining citizens confidence in their
elected leaders uh properly performed
audits provide independent assurance
that financial information presented is
reliable because of this New Hampshire
law mandates that all municipalities
with populations of greater than 750
conduct an annual audit now over the
last 20 years the wizville fire district
attempted to complete just one audit and
that was in
2014 that audit was not completed
because officials in the district
refused to turn over the necessary
documents over a dispute about
confidentiality uh since 2014 the
district elected numerous Auditors and
made statements both to the public and
to the Dr that they had audited
financials however after we investigated
the situation we realized that the
locally elected auditor never actually
performed an audit and the audited
financial statements they claimed to
have were nothing more than unaudited
financial statements the first time we
actually saw a movement toward
completing an audit was when s SP 414
was introduced last year this bill which
passed the House and Senate impos the
same penalties that this bill does for
not completing their audits in a timely
fashion as a result of the pressure put
on the district in 2020 they engaged The
Firm of plazak and Sanderson to complete
at least five years of audits to date
they have completed three of these
audits these audits reveal numerous
violations of State statutes these
include violations of RSA 32 the
municipal budget law RSA 33 the
municipal Finance act an additional
violations of RSA
41 uh some of the potential violations
or violations actually include taking
out loans without first getting approval
from the voters under New Hampshire LW
you're supposed to get 60% approval from
the voters uh they took out loans
without getting any support from the
electorate filing incomplete or
misleading forms with the Dr that
concealed these loans and making risky
Investments that are contrary to state
law the Dr is in the process of further
investigating these potential
violations um uh this includes
co-mingling of funds the audits also uh
detail concerns that are not under the
purview of the Dr one such example which
has been talked about was a district
falsely reporting to the New Hampshire
retirement system over an 11-year period
of about an employee that they had misc
Mis Mis categorized in addition to the
numerous violations of State statutes
the audit detailed how the district had
no meaningful internal controls in place
that would help minimize the risk of
fraud or human error in fact the audit
States the following based upon the
results of the audit procedures and
observations made during the audit we
noted the district has a lack of
internal control and Direction regarding
the accounting system and overall fiscal
mismanagement uh we have significant
concerns that without the passage of
Senate Bill 26 the district will have
little incentive to complete the two
years of remaining audits we believe the
potential penalties
imposed uh by last year's SB 414 is what
forced Woodsville Water and Light hand
and in in 20120 and without that the
three years of audits we now have would
not have been completed therefore the Dr
believes is in par if those penalties
contained in s sp26 are enacted if the
legislature Wishes the Dr to have a
meaningful and effective way to enforce
compliance with RSA 4131 a and just on a
on a final note um I'm I'm I'm assuming
I misheard uh a couple of speakers
because I believe they said there was
absolutely no way there was any
comingling of funds and the audit showed
that uh where of course on I'm looking
at page 46 of and I just grabbed the
2016 audit uh under the non-compliance
with State statutes payment in L of
taxes Pro from proprietary fund
surpluses we identified three transfers
of
$15,000 each made from accumulated fund
balances of water fund electric fund and
Sewer fund to the district's general
fund as a payment Al of taxes these
transfers were made contrary to the
provision of RSA 30 8 29 water funds and
RSA 14910 sewer fund what those statutes
with those RSA do is prevent the co-
mangling of funds which their own
Auditors said they did so again I must
have misheard them when they said there
wasn't that was not going on um I will
now uh certainly open up for any
questions you may
have I do
have those audits
online or or
not uh I don't believe we we the Dr does
not audits online we do not have those
audits online but they are publicly
available and If you could you send you
the three years of audits that I have to
you sir if if you
could send them to me as chairman and
you can find my my email and any member
who wants it I can forward it on for you
but I think that for some of us um
probably don't want
three large volumes of
audits but I can get them out two people
I think that some of us are going to
want to look at them before we make it
final decision on what to do with this
bill that's not a
problem uh Thompson thank you Mr
chairman Mr Gary do you
um does the Dr determine whether any of
these or is it your purview to determine
whether any of these issues of are
criminal or just uh a lack of knowledge
on on
the part of the people who uh put
themselves in place in management
positions yeah thank you thank you for
your question uh we only determine
what uh violates the laws that we deal
with which is mainly the municipal
budget act the municipal Finance act and
say 41 we do not assign criminality to
that that would be uh the Department of
Justice that would would handle that
that is not something the Dr is involved
with thank you any further
questions see thank you very much for
scking around and answering our
questions
um I do have sen of the guer you had
your hand up a while a minute ago um if
you want to speak I will give you a
second bite at the Apple for about three
minutes Mr chairman you you were blocked
as far as as I was being signed in by
your uh your Zoom controller so I'm not
sure what you said
um you had your hand up and I was
willing to give you a second shot at the
Apple um but very very
briefly thank you Mr chairman and I
appreciate the uh the Indulgence very
quickly here you are as a State
Legislative
committee okay digging into details of
what is clearly a local
matter and the point I'm trying to make
and asking you to support
Senate Bill
26 is this is not where this committee
belongs this is not a state issue of
funding it's not a state issue of
Transportation or Public
Works the legislature has no place here
passing this law will harm nothing it
will in fact facilitate moving
forward because at that point there will
be no state law preempting the ability
of local agencies to move forward and
having to bring this before a state
legislature whose Duties are to the
state and not to the if you will uh
assessing uh funding requirements on
local communities for the sake of other
local communities so with great respect
for the duties that you fulfill in
covering our state's
highways this is a law that needs to go
away so that the problem can in fact be
solved in the words of Representative
lad been dealing with this since
2004 trying to change it can't happen
trying to change or alter that
relationship cannot happen with this
Statute in place as it is hence the
origin of Senate Bill 26 the passage of
which will in fact enable the
communities to work forward
constructively with no blockade
established by state law thank you Mr
chairman yes thank you Mr thank you
Senator um you said that there really is
no role for the state here but
one of the things we heard was that
uh a source of the conflict is how State
Highway fund re Revenue sharing to to
haal get split up among the different
towns and different precincts and um
that does seem to be a state issue and
one of the ones that we've certainly
dealt with in this committee uh you know
the the local tax portion of
it I I think it's just a wash I mean if
U if ha wants to take their money and
Ville takes their money then you know
that's that's how this Village uh
Precinct system
works uh really is no change there the
only change is how how they deal with
the money that comes from the state with
all due respect representative um that
is not correct the highway block grant
money is in fact distributed fully in
accord with state law the percentages
based on population and so forth mileage
there is no change that this in no way
impact the distribution of block grant
this bill only impacts and requires
raising and appropriating local funds by
one community and requiring by state law
that those funds be given to another
community so there's no impact
whatsoever on the highway block grants
thank
you thank you
Senator I have no other hands rais for
anybody wishing to speak um I will close
the public hearing
on Senate
Bill six
um thank everybody for sticking around
for two hours of
testimony as as many of you know I had
hoped to exec this bill
today however given the fact that I have
asked for the audit to forwarded to us
um J bercher had a lot of Statistics she
was going to send us uh Mr PL and Mr
Shelton both had said they were GNA send
their written testimony I think that we
need to take some time look through all
of this information before we make a
final decision rather than jump into it
today um I know some of us are probably
ready to to say let's finish this and
get it over with but I think we need to
do it right um our
um executive session on this bill will
be on the 19 Wednesday the 19th of
May we'll be in the hybrid uh
situation um I will work with the uh
ranking member on a good time whether
it's morning or afternoon and we'll talk
about that I just asking um so I think
that it will behoove all of us to look
through all all of the information we
already have look through some of the
history and look through the information
that will be
forthcoming I I think that in order to
do that we'll come to the right decision
and again we will have four choices you
know pass it kill it amend it or retain
it and work on it for the next few weeks
few months so that those are the options
that we will look at on the night
um representative Evil's hand is always
oh um I wondered if representative lad
could share the research that he had OSS
do for him on the legislative
history um you can find his email and
ask him for it okay I okay I'm not sure
he's still here I see I see it I see him
um and the other thing is I just was
trying to understand what the litigation
was and maybe he can tell tell us about
that
too representative lad did you hear the
request yes I did uh representative
Graham um yes I do have the uh
communication I got from Benoy peler I
will forward that on to you Mr chairman
you can distribute it to your
committee um also in regard to
litigation uh I I'm not really part of
this anymore however I can tell you that
there's sizable amount of dollar that's
being spent by both part parties on this
and of
course we finished the hearing on this
fill so I don't want to get too much
depth on things that were said in the uh
in the hearing and because we're not in
executive session either so we're kind
of outside the Realms of our our
boundaries here of what we should or
should not be
doing but the request for the U
um history is is
legitimate
any else from any members of the
committee on what the way forward is
this is one thing representative I
hardly concur with your decision I think
we need to take our time on this this I
just wouldn't want I don't think I'd
make a good decision today if I had to
vote why our decisions are
always yeah I I'm just speaking for
myself I I
but I think that there's a lot of head
shaking I think a lot of people want to
look at um do our due diligence and make
sure we we've come to the right decision
um and another two weeks isn't going to
kill um whatever there is for for this
bill or black
there any other questions from members
of the committee to me about the way
forward um I as I said in my last email
there will be at least two days for
sessions in uh the first week of June
um we've got all the Senate bills to
handle um
so stay tuned for you know date time and
place and all that stuff in the
calendar and with
that we are adjourned
until the 19th of May thank you all for
sticking with it all
day thank you